When I'm driving around that corvette.
The corvette doesn't have a radio.
It's one of the best teams.
Yeah.
You know what and have them know radio
when you drive around with no radio.
D Two one live.
When I was a young and I
used to deliver newspapers,
my car didn't have radio and I used to
come up with some of my best shit like
for like standup comedy
material with no radio.
Just drive it around doing other things
cause I had a fold newspapers up and
throw him out the window.
And when you have no radio you have,
you're forced to think. And when you
force a thank you think about shit.
When he forced to think
about shit you got,
it's like we're constantly distracted,
man.
We want to look at our phone all the time.
When I see this podcast today,
ladies and gentlemen, no laptop. I'm
trying the new thing. Jamie, Nice.
No laptop. I'm trying. And then if I got
Jamie here, if I need to Google some shit,
boom here,
I probably should have tweeted it's
about to start here at Twitter right now.
That might help. That might help,
but there you are. Yeah. Here I am.
Distracted, distracted.
It's important man.
I mean once it in the car,
you spent so much time in the car and
you listened to music and just to pass
time.
Exactly with you man.
Well one thing that's good though
is a podcast and books on tape.
I do. I do really enjoy
doing that. I so I,
I think that like having the
option is probably better,
but the corvette doesn't have radio
and I just, I liked not having a radio.
I like sometimes just drive it around
just being alone with the thoughts here in
the rumble of the engine. You
know, if I had that engine, yes.
Well your engine is pretty fucking
sweet. Sound intense, dope.
But it's not that corvette think sounds
well it's a different kind of thing.
But you wouldn't want to live with that
everyday either. You'd get annoyed.
Correct. Alright. You're fucking loud.
It'd be like living with
a crazy coked up stripper.
It's just going to say that it's like
dating stripper ban. It seems fun.
Every now and then it gets real.
But not just living with her,
but like she would have to drive you to
work and everyone sees you look at hey
and she's got tattoos on her
Mac and cheese loud and
she smells like calm.
I was like, Oh, this is fun on Saturday.
Yeah. Like listen lady, I'm almost 30
years old. I got to get my life in order.
You got to get out of my fucking life. I'm
at Starbucks, which I need you to play.
That's what happens when you're, when
you're young, like those things are okay,
but as you get older you realize like,
hmm, this is not fun. This is just,
there's a lot happening. So I think
it's fun when I'm drunk, you know?
Well I think it's good for like once
or twice a week and then the girl true.
It depends what they were talking about.
Cars for the group depends on the guy.
We are talking about cars,
we're talking about all things.
You don't want to watch an action
movie every fucking day. Hell No.
You don't want to watch
explosions and fucking missiles.
[inaudible] you want to watch like
stepbrothers, fun, mix it up, mix it up.
And I love ice cream but I want every day.
That's
right.
Mixing it up is big and that's
what people with everything, right?
Everything man. We were talking about it
off the air. People get too comfortable.
They do never comfortable.
You know,
one of the things that would freak
me out lately, not freaking me out,
but it's been like,
I've been like wha wondering on it.
Like on my message board sometimes I'll
have a guest and then I'll read like
after the podcast that like for like,
it's almost like half and
half sometimes like Ha,
I had this Guy Milo Yiannopoulos,
you Annapolis, Annapolis,
uh, on the other day,
hilarious guys,
gay guy.
He's a blog or really funny blogger.
Lives in England and he was over here
from London and some people love the
podcasts on people. Fucking
hated it. Worst podcasts ever.
This was shit. Oh my God,
this was just hilarious. I love
that guy. He's so entertaining.
I want to drown him in a toilet bowl.
It's like you can't,
that's what you want though. Yeah. You
kind of, that's kind of what you want,
that you want to, as long as they're
talking about it, you're good.
You cannot make every, it's not possible
to make everyone happy. It does.
The only person who ever made
everyone happy was bill Cosby.
He was the only guy. I'm not, I'm
not choking. He was the only guy.
You're right. He didn't, but he was
the only guy that for a long time.
You never heard God damn bad thing. Nah,
those Jello commercials pissed me off
that bullshit sweater all the time.
Black blacking up.
He was so good as a comic and so
good as the host of a show and it's,
the Cosby show was so well done that
literally no one spoke ill of them and all
the while he's drugging
checks and ray brown
dude, but he might be the only guy.
There's like a few like Anthony Hopkins,
you know, there's a few actors, but no
one knows him. You know what I'm saying?
Niggas feel like we feel like we
know bill Cosby or we thought we did.
We thought we did.
I feel like Jay Leno was one of those
guys in what most people love Jay Leno.
You don't hear a bad thing about
it. Really? Oh, that's so not true.
My way off on this. Yeah, you're
so off. Yay. Let, first of all,
I love David Letterman might hate him.
Not just a Letterman,
but there was a bunch of
fans of Conan O'brian.
There was a whole situation where Conan
took over the tonight show and then
remember Jay Leno had a show before him
and then it became like this crazy thing
where the tonight show wasn't
doing so well. Well, yeah.
This is like Cosby rape and bitches.
Just before that, before that,
before we knew that people still
didn't like him, man. Yeah. Yeah.
There was certain, first of all,
shops love Jay Leno, my household.
What state was this again for Denver?
Colorado sounds about right. We love,
especially Lamprey,
weed being legal debt,
living on a farm with really
good electricity that's
being on a ranch somewhere. So
people that, a satellite dish.
But I think, um, uh, there was a lot
of people from the Howard Stern group,
like for standup comics,
Jay Leno at one point in time,
it was like one of the top comics in
the country, real edgy, real edgy.
When he was young, he would go
on David Letterman, be like this,
like super edgy guy.
And then for some comics it felt like
when he started hosting the tonight show,
he kind of became more middle America
and became more, but he did it.
It's like it was a calculated move
on his part. Smart move. Really.
It was a smart man. He's more, he's
more corporate you're saying right.
It kind of sold out. Oh, a hundred percent
corporate Conard percent corporate,
we say sold out.
I don't know,
because I think people who like what
he's doing still think what he's doing is
great.
He just found a broader market that
maybe might not appeal to like younger,
more hardcore people the way a real sharp
guy like Letterman or maybe Colin and
Colin has some of the best writers in
all of a late night. I love coding. Yeah.
Especially like when he was on in
the late night show in New York,
he had like I had my buddy
used to work for him,
I got to see like one of their very
first shows, you know how they have it,
like we're having this banter back and
forth because we're just talking to
friends just shooting the shit when it
would appear that they were doing that.
But behind them there was placards that
have every word they were supposed to
say. So their conversations
were fake blood. Yeah. Yeah.
They had a fake conversation so they'd be,
so I went to the zoo yesterday.
So someone's holding up zoo. Yup.
Yup. Right behind him. They had,
everything was rehearsed and everything
was preplanned and eventually he got
away from that.
And I think in the beginning they were
nervous because he was a writer and so he
really didn't have a lot of
performance experience cause he,
cause he wrote for Senate
live and Simpsons, right? Is
that correct? I believe so.
I don't know.
But I know he was going to be super
respected writer and a really funny guy.
And the thought was that he
was the guy that was like,
it was always really funny in the room,
like when he would meet with executives
and writers, he was like the funny guy,
really strong, intelligent,
funny guy. And they're like,
this guy should be a host of a fucking
show. And then they decided to, you know,
build it up and make it work.
But in the beginning they laid literally,
it's probably micro management
on the network side.
They were probably just
fucking with his show too much.
They didn't just allow it. They're
scared what it is. Yeah, sure.
They're taking a big chance
of having them there.
So it was weird that there they're coming,
I don't remember what my original
point was, but their conversation, oh,
this is what it was there.
The conversation was written out though.
So it was like the writers, what
really sharp dudes that were trying to,
and then they came out with all these
different characters and reoccurring
themes and everything that
they would use on the show.
And it became like a real cohesive thing.
And then when he went to the tonight show,
they change the show.
Like all of a sudden he was doing
like the tonight show, you know,
it's like the whole thing was different.
The feel is different.
You got to do what got you to the dance.
Not only that,
when they did at Jay Leno was number one,
like when they had Jay Leno step out
and they put Conan O'brian in, they,
I think they probably,
you know,
they have these weird things where
they base it on how old people are.
Like if you're old as fuck,
they don't want you because all
people don't spend any money.
They want those 1834
year old men who are single. That's,
that's the, that's the real money.
The real money is in young dudes who
spend money on stupid shit and they
probably easily influenced by commercials.
So they didn't fucking shit. I know
that, I see those KFC
commercial, they fucking go.
But there was also this thing where the
Howard stern show was pissed at him and
Howard stern was pissed at
Jay Leno because someone,
whoever it was on the Jay Leno writing
staff most likely was ripping off ideas
from the Howard stern show.
Allegedly. I've never examined this,
but I remember Howard being really
pissed about it and he's not unreasonable
when it comes to stuff like that.
It doesn't make sense how it's
a powerful dude too. Yeah.
I think also like sometimes
writers do shit like that, man,
that's happened like a gang
at times with standups.
Writers will come to see you perform
and then they turn your bits and like a
part in a sitcom that happened
to Kevin James. I witnessed it.
I saw the whole thing.
It's happened to several guys and a
bunch of different shows and well,
you know what it is like
say if you're a writer,
you're a young kid from fucking
Cleveland and you get a Gig writing for
crystally his show, right? You
got to be assigning a man. Yeah.
You got some fucking demands and some
of these guys will come to comedy clubs
and they'll just pull a pill
for idea. It's a bad idea, man.
I mean just shitty at your
job. It does. It does,
but it also means you're trying to get by.
Fake it till you make it pregnant job,
but you can't fake it off
other people's ideas though.
I bet you're going to get caught up.
I agree.
I think a lot of them is no longevity
and they think they're not going to get
caught up. True. They think they're
just going to get away with it.
Just do it now and then.
I'm really good.
They just don't know it unless Joe
Rogan sees that shit or anybody now.
You know when I,
when we put out that youtube video of
them and see a thing that was a long ass
time ago. I just saw that like couple
months ago. That shit was awkward.
It's so awkward.
What'd you get on stage like?
Well, I was on stage before him. I
know the stories coming up. Right.
He actually wasn't supposed to be on.
He took the microphone away
from the guy who was next,
the guy who was next to this guy,
Kirk Fox.
He just debotta like give me the mic
because I brought him up as a writer
because Kurt used to write for,
for Carlos and I said there was a writer
for Carlos men steal. Yeah. And so, uh,
that was it. That was it. It was a
straw that broke the camel's back.
But then you jump up there and then
you, and then he kept saying, he goes,
I have the mic. You don't
realize dummies. I have the mic.
And you like give me a fucking mic and
you get the Mike shut that shit down once
he's still alive. He's alive. Is he
still alive? Did you have him kill? No,
he's alive. The UFC mafia get
to him. Is He, is he dead?
He's out there doing standup still.
Yeah. Yeah. I hope he's doing well.
I hope he's doing well. Hope he's
doing his own shit. You know,
the problem with those guys are,
one of the big problems is when you steal,
you don't learn what it to come up with.
Bit like,
I've got a couple of bets right now
that they're, they might die there.
I'm looking at them, they're like, they'll
like bad dogs. Dogs are broken hips.
I'm like this mother fucker down.
So a horse sort of broken legs. See,
I'm trying to think if I should fix
the bit or if I was just tank it.
That's the battle though, right? It's
what makes you great. It's the, well,
it's the only way to make a bit good.
You gotta bring that motherfucker out
to the light of day and you got to tweak
it and roll it.
And there's some times that bit's just,
they just don't seem like
they're gonna make it.
And sometimes you gotta let them go,
but that's why you're
making a living as comedian.
And then Carl has been seen as like,
fuck man, we still making a living.
He stopped was still probably does
really well, you think? Yeah. Yeah.
I mean he's a name,
you know,
he can go to weird spot and do comedy
clubs and still probably do pretty good.
But the reality is, you know,
when you, when you do that,
when you steal,
you usually steal because you're,
there's different mindset for a
plagiarist than there is for someone who's
creative.
And I think the mindset of someone who's
a plagiarist is the mindset of it's all
about me, so me getting this
stuff and then I'm going to do it.
I'm going to be a bad motherfucker.
It's about me.
Whereas I think the mindset of someone
who's more creative is all about whatever
the idea is and you're just sort of
like on a train to get the idea to the
people. What I think if you're creative
too, you see an idea and you're like,
well you, you viewed it from a
different filter. Does that make sense?
I can see the will, people can see an
idea and view it from a different filter.
Like I think this is the funny way.
Like this angle might be funny sometimes.
Yeah, sometimes. I mean, it really
depends entirely on the idea,
but I think the big factor,
one of the big factors is ego.
And if you have a big ego,
it can help you and it can fuck you.
It can do both.
It can help you in the gives you like
the courage and the belief in yourself,
even if it doesn't make any sense to
try something that's very difficult to,
it's huge, man. That's huge. At our
first live show, the first eight,
nine minutes was me by myself.
How's that?
Was the bit watts is sanded it off.
Who told whose idea was this?
Both of us. Why would you want
to do that? It went awesome, man.
You're talking about egos.
Egos and went great man.
Well People Love Dad came there to see
you, man. So he did stand up. Yeah,
basically. Basically like
told a story. Wow. Yeah.
And had this whole bit and
pieces you've done standup.
Your first standup was in front of a live
audience, right? It was a podcast. Yeah.
That's crazy. Yeah. That's crazy.
Your first stand up Everest
on the Internet. Yeah. Whoa.
That's not what we are.
We're not releasing it though. Oh, you
haven't released it. We're not going to.
People want to release it last. I'll
release my, my, my standup portion,
but we want to make it special for
the life fans. People hate that.
Why would you want to do that?
They're already there.
It was very west special for them.
They bought,
probably want to hear it again and then
a bunch of other people want to hear it
too.
But yeah.
So come to the other live shows.
We're doing all these tours. No,
you think we should release it like
their accounts idea? We'll probably mind.
Yeah. Um, I was thinking
as to retard to be yours.
This is my only thing.
I honestly think it's special
for these people live there live.
It's already special for them.
They probably want to hear it again.
There's probably a lot of people that
were there that said that was a really
good time. I would love to share
that again in my, on my commute.
And then there's other
people that weren't there,
which you going to punish them
because they couldn't get to break.
That's what you're doing.
That's what you doing, man.
Recording released the house.
Unless you're thinking about,
oh,
you should release it 100% full fuck.
Do I have to do well,
you should should. It's good. If it's
good, you should release it. It's great.
Then you should definitely release it.
Why not release it?
Because we're doing a nationwide
tour. Good. Keep doing it.
Like you would bring more people to the,
to the actual live.
They're going to come anyway.
Don't worry about it. Yes. God,
what are you worried about? This 350
million people out there. You can't.
You you need to do is clone yourselves
and have more shows to do them in more
spots.
Well you don't need to worry about is
people not showing up at a spot because
they heard alive. Unless the live
podcast sucks. If you come up with a dud,
you do have that advantage, but if you
come up with a dud, you could tank it.
Like if for whatever reason
just goes awful. Just bombed.
Excuse. You know, if someone has to
roofie you or something before the show,
they could, you never know. You just
start talking. I'll tell you what, man,
we did live questions and use. Usually
we filter them. Some girl, you know,
like I've never been on stage relates
brightest. Fuck. They give them Mike,
some girls shields. Shab uh, do you
remember to me, do you remember me?
I propose to you four years ago
at the UFC expo and you said, yes,
we're the fucks my ring. I was like, what
the fuck? I'm trying to look like fuck.
Is that moving on? Next
question. Next question. Uh,
Brandon, what do you think of?
And it's some Ronda Rousey
question. Next question. Oh,
how much would Reebok next question.
Oh yeah, it was fun to mix it up, man.
I get that though. So you're
involved a lot of controversial shit.
Really tell him the truth. Oh,
you're going to be real honest. Yeah.
I mean, being honest. Don't
you think that's controversial?
I guess it is for an athlete.
I guess I'm supposed to be this fucking
cookie cutter and get in line and it's
just,
I don't know what,
you just have terrible PR skills
and it turns out it works.
It depends how you look at it. What is
PR though? It's public relations. See,
that's where they're wrong because your
public relations skills are awesome
because everybody knows you don't really
have a very good filter. No filter.
Your filter is like a bunch of string
in front of a river trying to keep the
salmon out.
It's like you need a need more than that.
They're going to get through
that and they go over rocks.
You got to have more than that,
man.
It's like a moment of pause where they
get to this training and they go, ah,
what am I doing here? I'm going to do,
someone asked me a question like, oh,
fucking don't worry about it.
You're a good guy. Yeah, sure. Try.
If you're a good guy,
just be yourself.
If you're a good guy and you're telling
the truth, I don't see why there,
why you wouldn't just keep doing it.
Like I was training the other day and this
guy came up to me, he goes, man, dude,
I love what you do. You know, you give me
motivation to do some outside fighting,
blah, blah, blah. He
goes, but, but he goes,
I wish I could talk about some
stuff. You'll do it, man. Oh, oh,
he wishes he could do the same kind
of, but yeah, he just goes, I wish.
He goes, I wish I just can't.
Like some people, well,
he might not be able to now and the road
for him to get to the point where he
can is long,
but people that,
people always think that they are who
they used to be. Does that make sense?
It's like people look at themselves like
say if you were a loser in high school
and you fuck,
there's a lot of people that are haunted
by high school for like their whole
life or certain events.
Yeah. That's why for sure.
But that's why being bullied
and so dangerous to some
people because if they get
really fucked with by people and
tormented by people in high school,
that chicken carry over to wrestle live.
It did, it devastates their confidence.
So when the early developmental period
they have it's really poor self image and
having a poor self image is fucking super
hard to get over. It was really hard.
Well you know I've talked about before
in this, I've basically body dysmorphia,
which is fucking crazy man cause
I'm in great shape. But it,
and it happened in college.
I had this girlfriend for a long
time and I had this huge event. Uh,
I was getting ready to trap for
all these NFL teams and I, uh,
the night before I was going through all
my mental stuff on how it was going to
do and I put on exactly what I was
going to wear. And it's the, you know,
you don't know how to
act and eat like a pro,
but I did it for fuck four months and I
was like feeling good. And I'm like, damn,
do I look like an NFL guy right now?
This is how an Nfl guy looks right
and that my girlfriend, I go,
what do you think? How do I look? And
she goes, look a little soft. You look,
it looks soft. You're the kind of
Chubby. Wow. One girl got you. Got me.
I was literally like,
ever since then,
man gave me a fucking with you when she,
did she date some bodybuilders
before you or something?
So dude's cut weight and eat.
I think she was just trying to be honest.
Maybe she didn't have a filter. I don't
know. Make that pitch another pill.
Could we see? Yes. You look down under
the car. Did you immediately for calling?
You saw shortly after that, very shortly.
But you were like, why be the nerd?
But ever since then I was
like, damn. And then fuck that.
Fucking my competence the next day.
That can do that then yeah, if you let
it, and I think it's like snake venom.
Like you get a little bite.
Gil will bite every now and then.
I think it's good for you. Good, good.
You got to understand what's
happening when is insulted you,
you got to understand, you
know, and sometimes they're
just being honest with you.
True.
And there's a time for that,
but that was not the time for that.
You had a fucking shows
tryouts, big games. Big,
big event.
The next day based on my life up for
at the time is a huge event and she's
telling you soft,
tough man has a mean bitch.
Did you guys have fights before this?
Was She mad about something else? Uh,
I mean,
I'm sure I was a shitty boyfriend.
Did have another girlfriend at
the time. Yeah, I did. Okay.
We'll figure it out as a bad guy. Well,
I'm not a bad guy. I'm in college.
You're not going to get married. Yeah.
Young, dumb and full of cum. Yeah.
Yeah, it is. Right. That's why
that expression exists. Yeah, man.
When you say young and dumb and you never
heard young, dumb and full of calm, no.
Oh my God.
That's a old really up Jamie has,
that's all he's heard from me a hundred
times before. Rogue out. Yeah. Yeah, yeah,
for sure. It's not mine. I was, I think
it was around when I was in high school.
But you got some old school shit.
I think it's some old school shit,
but it's new school too because I've
heard it from people recently and someone
would have told me that in college
or high school. I'm like, damn,
that's aggressive man. Super. That's it.
But correct Jesus Christ. I know, right.
It's like you're just trying
to damn old air flow. Yeah.
But when you say that nobody goes, I don't
even understand. Everybody goes, yeah,
I get it. Yeah. Hundred.
Yeah, 100% that was me.
I was thinking about myself in high
school the other day for whatever reason.
You know like sometimes you have this
weird moment where you just think like,
wow,
what was it like to like to be like
if I had to go and do that again,
what was it really like?
What are my memories of it
and what was it really like?
Cause my memories of it were
all like, oh, always nervous.
Fucking never confident.
Always weirded out. Yeah. Yeah.
Trying to get away from everybody.
Always just, I was weird here.
That kid so weird.
I was accepted cause I like,
I fit in like the way
I looked fit athlete.
I didn't know anything about sports.
I don't know.
No sports and all I wanted to do
was kickbox so I wanted to do,
all I wanted to do was taekwondo and
kickbox one tough back then it was a,
I was so, I was such a Weirdo. It's
all I did all day. I was upset.
I was always insecure,
everything but that,
like when I did that
I was super confident.
Like I knew I was really good at that.
So there was like one thing I couldn't
wait to do and get the fuck away from
people. What about girls? I had a
couple of girlfriends. I did all right.
I was good looking guy. It wasn't, it
wasn't that hard of just, I wasn't like,
I wasn't very good socially. Not for
sure it wasn't good at it. I was like,
it wasn't really good at
that until I calmed down.
Like I don't think I was even that good
socially when I started doing stand up.
I think I got way better at it cause
I realized I need to, but I was,
I was like one of the things that I was
thinking when I first started doing it
was like, man, I wish that,
I wish I would just go back to competing
because in competing I didn't need
anybody's approval. I, I kinda liked it
if he didn't like me, I kind of liked it.
If there's a bunch of people cheering
against me, I was like, just wait,
wait to see what I do. They're like, wait
a minute. Yeah, it doesn't matter to me.
It just going to give
me some more motivation.
It's going to give some more intensity.
But with comedy everybody has to like
you and then you realize like you're not
that likable. Like just kidding. Yeah.
But like sometimes like things we do,
like things a person does,
you do to be successful,
but you're not thinking in
terms of like being liked.
Like I always wondered about like
guys who are extreme extreme winters,
guys like Lance Armstrong or guys like
Michael Jordan and they get reputations
of being not very good guys are
very nice guys or maybe greedy.
Like you always hear that about Jordan.
He doesn't selfie selfish. Selfish.
Yeah man.
Then you got to think like a guy like
that is so focused on this one thing.
He's so focused on winning.
You're so focused on just beating everyone
down and it's all about him and him
getting ahead.
You're so focused on that so you're
not thinking about how other people are
perceiving you cause you're like, fuck
them, I'm coming in a dunk on their face.
Yeah man. That's, well that's
what greatness requires.
That that's what I learned
through my journey of athletics.
The best players I've ever played with.
They weren't the friendliest,
oh the the the best fighters who I trained
with or best fighters that I ran with.
God, not the friendliest
man. Georges St Pierre.
Saint Pierre's is super fucking
friendly guy. He's like George George.
George is super friendly, super friendly.
I wouldn't say George is the most out.
There's a, there's always
something, George might be
the exception. George is, uh,
a very cerebral fighter.
I went say George isn't the most
outgoing guy, you know what I'm saying?
Like George is kind of an introverted
soul was picked on as a kid and stuff like
that. He, he's different. A
lot of the, the super winners,
they're just different
men and it's something,
maybe they are born with that or they
some event in their life happen or
something like that and they're
just these ultra winters.
And I could never relate to it.
I gotta be honest.
I wonder if being like that that's the
only way you become an ultra winter.
If you just think about the winning only,
you can't be this like really social
butterfly person that just goes around and
makes friends with everybody.
You gotta be some driven psycho that's
getting up at four 30 and running up
hills. Yeah, man. And then you
mix that with talent and how yeah.
Fucking the greatness. That's where the
greatness comes from, man. Yeah. You know,
I had a crazy conversation with
Bj Penn the other night. Um,
I just got texts out of the blue
from Bj called Bj up and a beanie.
Bj and I were talking about all sorts of
shit and he was talking to this friend
of his, who got his black
belt for years. You know,
Bj got his black belt in three and a
half years, which was crazy. Crazy.
So the guy, you know, and Bj talking
to in Bj goes, wow, that's amazing.
Congratulations. You must
be really talented. And he
goes, no. He goes, I'm, I was,
I'm addicted. He goes, I'm
addicted to Jujitsu just like
you, you were addicted to.
And Bj Sat. But he goes, I never thought
about it that way. And then he goes,
I realize, yeah, I was addicted. I mean,
that's why I got my black belt
in three and a half years.
I was addicted and we were laughing.
He was talking about how he's addicted.
So he like final fantasy.
You're playing game. I have
one in like eighth grade. He plays
that shit. He got no one point though.
He got addicted to that game. That's
just, again, that's how these,
that's how these crazy successful people
are. The, there is no one foot in,
one foot out. It's fucking all
in men and nothing else matters.
Nothing else matters. Yeah. That might
be my problem. Joe. You're too nice.
Um, but on occasionally, like I wash
our cro cop fight the other day.
You weren't very nice. No fight.
That was not nice. You know,
you were super aggressive in that
fight. I was, you know, it's weird, man.
It's like I watched the, uh, the,
the Alexander in DC fight where it's
back and forth and I used to get inspired
by those. Right. I used to,
I used to watch a great fight
and as soon as they ended,
I hit the ground running. Well,
I love to run. I would just run.
That's how I dealt with being
nervous and what's next for me.
I just start fucking running now.
When I see that stuff,
I think first about their health, I'm
like, damn, what? I hope he's okay.
Yeah. And I felt that change in me and I'm
like, that's, well that's not good. Yeah,
that's not good. That's not
good. Don't get me wrong. I
still appreciate it. Great.
Fine. I fucking love fighting.
I don't miss a fight.
I view it different now
instead of thinking that was
amazing fight. I think, man,
I hope they're okay.
Hopefully they're not too injured
and what's next after this?
Even if you win the belt. All right
man, what's after this? Cause I, I've,
I have friends who have
one belt and you know,
they're not fucking killing it these days.
It seems like it's one of those
things where you just have to,
you have to be able to put
aside any thoughts of the
damage that you're doing to
yourself.
You've got to be able to just do it.
And now as soon as you start taking
into consideration that damage and it
becomes, that extra factor becomes that
extra thing that you have to think about,
you know,
that that can fuck with.
And also that thing that can fuck with
greatness like we were talking about,
about greatness is like this obsession
plus talent, dedication and drive.
But then you add the variable of
fear of injury or concern or playing
conservative to avoid
injury. I agree. I think, um,
I was obsessed with fighting and
I think if you ask anyone who,
who trained with me or,
um, one of my coaches, man,
hardest work in the room, Shab
by far I was crazy. Crazy.
But then when it came time to fight,
you ever seen the old school robo cop?
When he's about to attacks on,
it's like calculating and it's
like fucking 70% of gun here.
That's how my fucking mind works,
man. I don't know what to do.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, uh, my last fight, I'm
sitting there and I'm like,
I know here you can close this. I know
he's going to kick in too much. Um,
and yeah, I'm thinking too, I'm too,
so rebel. I'm thinking way too much.
While they're probably not like that,
they're going, they're in the zone.
They're in the zone there. They're
fighters. They're going, yeah, it's tough,
man.
Well, it's one of the most
difficult things I think for,
for people to do is get in that zone to
figure out that that place that you get
to where you're just relying on all
of your training and you're just their
instincts. That happened to me
once, once Gabriel, Gonzaga.
Really only once. Only once. I don't
know why. Could not tell you why. Well,
I think I remember that fight.
Just everything was slow motion.
I didn't hear the crowd.
Everything you through I already
saw coming and it was just like,
it was just like this white noise.
That's a one time I've been in the zone.
Never gotten the zone and football
really. Maybe once, but fighting, it's a,
it's a fricking to get there, man
is unreal. Well, it's different.
It's like if you get in the
zone with a plain pink pawn,
the loss of getting in the zone, it's,
it's not dangerous to your health. Yeah.
I, the thing about fighting that
makes it different than anything else,
even more difficult than Jujitsu cause
Jujitsu's nerve wracking and when to
watch two guys going at it and
they're trying to kill each other.
They're nervous as fuck before that,
you know,
but they're not as worried about injury.
It's a different kind of injury.
Cause the Jujitsu injury you might get
choked, you might get your arm snapped.
It is possibly get hurt me.
You could always embarrassed,
right or you could land wrong.
Fuck your knee up or fuck your neck up.
But it does happen. It is
possible. But MMA or kickboxing,
anything along those lines.
Moitai yeah,
I watched this Moy Tai knock out the other
day. Oh my God, it was fucking insane.
Some guy from Thailand,
I wish I knew who it was cause it was an
animated Gif that someone's sent me and
this dude hits this guy with the,
he's got them in a Thai clinch.
He hits his guys with this fucking
ridiculous knees to the body like three
Riddick boom, boom, boom.
And they go into the ropes and then
dude hits him with a flying knee that is
just the most perfectly time
flying knee snaps his head back.
His body goes limp and he just slides
against the ropes and down to the ground,
but it was just the poetry of it and
the explosiveness of it that just boom,
boom, boom and he flies through the
air, Bang, hits him in the flying knee,
like the fact that that
could happen to you
and you get in there with a guy who's
training how they mean you just like
hoping he doesn't know how to do that.
Yeah, well especially this day and age,
you know I was watching the last UFC,
I was watching the last UFC and that that,
what's this? I forget his first
name. The Rodriguez Feller.
I air GI here and the Northcott.
Northcott. I watch. Yeah,
year Rodriguez and I'm like,
what the fuck? Well you
know what the difference is?
The fuck is going on taekwondo,
taekwondo,
those guys have all the other
shit to Northcote this small.
I did some research on this kid.
Oh Yeah,
the smallest dad has him fucking
do all this crazy stuff. I'm like,
that's the future, man. It's
neck. And then I watched two,
uh, you know, I'm, I going
to say her name. I'll watch
two other guys who, you know,
we're kind of the same class.
They're a
little older than me.
I watched him fight after
watching Rodriguez in north
gut and then watching them
fight. I'm like, I'm watching.
I go, that's how I fight, man.
That's what it looked like.
Like you fucking went all throwback
Thursday in the middle of the card.
You know what I'm saying? Like these
guys are just boxing, wrestling,
and then you see these young guys
and it's like, fuck man. Yeah.
Yeah. Did you see that?
Uh, what is his name?
Macramed off the Russian dude
that fought Sean Jordan. Yes.
God Damn,
that guy can throw some fucking kicks.
You see that front leg question Mark
Hickey was hitting him with yes,
but it's more of a
taekwondo point scoring.
Like no one's going to be scared
of those kicks. Cool. Great.
Even his punches, all the slapping
you, he's moving, he's moving.
He's going to be in trouble when
he gets in there with a killer.
Maybe not that Jordan's not a killer,
but a guy who can deal with that
maybe and hits for heavyweight.
I was almost a little bit of a a point
score where it's so much footwork and I'd
touch and move, touch and move. When you
get a heavyweight and he's gonna. Okay,
touch, touch, judge whacked. Right.
It's like a heavyweight is when he get
in trouble being a lighter heavyweight
maybe. What is he to 40 he's not
lying. He was two 36 I think.
[inaudible] that'd be a lighter,
heavier anything on I considered lighter
canes to 40 and he carries a roll of
fat on them. Now would you say
Keynes, a knockout artist? I wouldn't.
I wouldn't say he's a knockout artist,
but you wouldn't want to get hit by him.
But came guy who stands outside
and point points, moods get puts,
gets under hook, puts his head in
your chest and makes you do it.
Does work completely different fighter
mag man seems to fight like more
strategically.
Avoid damage first and then land
shots and don't drain your gas tank.
I agree.
Which is smart at heavyweight.
So he's a certain point because then you
can get a guy who's not going to play
that game. Well we'll see. We'll see
what happens to him as he moves up.
You know and we'll see. What am impressed
with is his technique though. I agree.
His counter punching was nasty.
He liked that question.
Mark kick does not have a lot of
power behind it. That's a fact.
But the fact that he throws it
like that off of his front leg,
like for folks who don't know
how hard that is to do, that's,
that requires like some crazy dexterity.
And to see that from a heavyweight,
it's pretty rare for the listeners.
Most people will know Donald
Cerrone for Donald throws him a lot.
He throws buffer a heavyweight
too. It's pretty crazy. Yeah.
And Well Donald doesn't throw it that
much off his front leg though. Donald Can,
he can certainly count. He'll use the
bag. But that guy was throwing it like,
like a whip office front, like
it was coming up. And then swap,
but just there wasn't much behind
it. That'd be my, the, his footwork.
Everything is cardio's great
counter punching dope everything.
But you're going to heavyweight
where they're going to make it count.
Sean Jordan. It's tough
as fuck man. You know,
he broke his rib in that first round.
Yeah, he's went back to his corn.
So all those broken, you never
saw it from his effort. You know,
he never laid back and they were put his
arm over it. Ever tried to protect it.
He uh, he had to gut it out while that
guy was staying on the outside land and
combinations. Yeah, that main main
event saved that card for sure.
That main event was amazing.
Those guys like sage Northcutt though.
And here's another one.
Wonderboy Thompson.
Wonderboy is the motherfucker right now.
He's a motherfucker because everybody,
like in the beginning it was about
taking him down and grappling with them.
But now that he's been spending so much
time with Weidman and he's learning how
to grapple learning,
grappling, defense correctly,
you're going to see more of what
you saw in the Ellenberger fight.
Guys that are forced to stand up with the
true and joy that you have a good time.
We can we finding a snake,
can we call them wonder man though?
He's 34 couldn't five like what the fuck
is there any way we can use that wonder
man? He can keep it. Yeah. He keeps
wheel kicking people in the head.
He can keep it as the only
thing coming up. I don't know.
I think you're always fighting.
He got surgery. I know.
Get from person a to bring him in
was named Mark Cart and Denver.
Nate met him through I think a church
thing, whatever, how that goes.
So brought him down and he's just this
bad ass in the gym but had zero grappling.
But standing with them
was a fucking nightmare.
And then Nate told George about them
and then we see Thomson up north and he
starts getting his grappling in.
And then when he got to the UFC,
I think he was doing well with matchups
and then he got Matt Brown, right? Yeah.
That's when he got in trouble. Yeah.
Matt Brown beat him up. And he also, uh,
was overtrained for
that fight. He said, uh,
he came in that fight real flat and he
knew it was in trouble even before Matt
Brown. He's like not taking anything
away from Matt Brown. He goes,
I just could not recover.
But yeah, he survived though.
He made it to the third
round. He's a beast man that
came down to watch for sure.
Now he's so nasty. I agree. But what
those guys can do that guys like him guys,
I got a year and code.
We're a sage Northcutt rather sage
Northcutt has that front leg kick that he
throws and he is very
unusual because he throws,
he stands orthodox and throws his front
leg side kick off his left leg and it's
a really good front leg side kick. So
you, so you've seen his previous fights,
was he seven to oh seven to nine other
previous sites for getting the UC?
I haven't seen anything besides,
I've seen a few of his fights. Okay.
I've been watching him for awhile. I've
been hearing about him for a while too.
Um, but what he's, what he's
got is a, uh, an unusual,
he's got a very high level of like
karate and kickboxing and talk window,
very high level of taekwondo skill,
but then also ridiculous athleticism.
Like he does front flips here.
That's what I see out of it.
Doesn't most Flint front flips and lands
on the tips of his toes and like gently
comes down to his heel.
It's not like a clumsy bounce.
It's like this effortless flip where
he knows exactly where the ground is
stocked as Instagram.
I saw him doing some crazy shit like
caring wheels and shit up sand hills.
He's a free look at this.
We have this flip.
I mean it looks like it's like some
moon landing shit that looks fake.
It looks like a model too.
He looks like what the fuck is going
on Paige vanzant if she was a boy,
those two need to procreate.
No they don't.
They'll be like some Uber race. Look at
how he does that. Doesn't use your mill.
That literally looks like someone's
got wires attached to it saying,
I'll give you, showed this to Eddie
Bravo and put some chem trails behind it.
He would be absolutely,
dude,
he's going off for an hour for Northcott
and half the class right now. I put, ah,
dude,
you don't use a student at Texas a and
m o was talking about dropping out to do
fighting full time now man. Nah, no
way. Whoa, whoa. Because it pussy.
Yeah. Texting him. Johnny Manziel
who used to run that page.
Now it's you. Mr Northcutt. He's,
I don't think he needs any help.
I think it's probably better if he takes
breaks. Nest a break every now and then.
You know, I think he's Uber religious.
I don't think he cares about that.
That's not good. That'll build
up. Kid needs an outlet. Yeah.
Those flips won't be happening
like that after a while. Well,
a body like that needs to fuck.
He got a little bit,
I kick to be extra just like those quads.
100% don't sleep on that Dick.
Don't cut. His wrestling is good
too though. I mean, he's not like,
he's not like the best in the
world at anything but all together.
It's a nasty pack. He's good at
everything and his athleticism is going,
came so far and he's only 19 he's
going to be so much better in a month.
You know? It's a little scary being 19
and being in the UFC already is there.
Yeah, you can be champion with it,
but let's say he loses three in a row.
Well that's not what's, what's scary to
me is that he is overmatched quickly.
But that's what I'm saying. We don't
know. We don't know if that even can.
Michael McDonald, Michael McDonald,
19 years old fought Miguel Torres.
Dude Mcdonald before he lost he rife
favor and before he lost a Hennen,
Barao was a motherfucker. Motherfucker.
Motherfucker. Motherfucker.
Isn't that a perfect, it's a perfect
example. He cares, but you can't do it.
This kid can do like with flips and stuff,
but Michael McDonald knocks
motherfuckers into oblivion punches.
Where's Michael McDonald right now?
When's the last time he's
heard from [inaudible]? He's
been injured for how long?
Two years. I think he got hurt pretty
bad. I don't know what the injury was.
I don't even know if he's,
he was up close as it fucker for awhile.
I'm just saying the only thing that
scares me is like if, if we, uh,
reference boxing. So a 19 year olds
going to have how many amateur fights?
Fucking 300 before they get to
turn pro. Right? This is bay.
We're seeing Northcott's career amateur
career right now with only seven fights.
What the fuck? Seven fights.
Ain't shit. Well that's,
let's say when it's three and he's a star.
Hey my man.
Or You went to more your star. There's,
hey bro, there's nowhere to go.
We have to toss you to these monsters.
There's no buildups for three years.
Trust me. You would know.
That's an interesting point.
That's what's, that's what's tough
about this sport. Like a page, right?
She's phenomenal. She looks great.
Speaks great chess skills. Cool man.
Let's build this up. She can be your
one 15 pound champ, but she's won what?
Two or three now? All right.
Well in that women's Davinci.
So thin we're going to throw
you some mother fuckers.
Well how about the motherfucker?
She's ranked seventh
at the top of the list
is a goddamn murderer straightening
yarder yawn is a murderer.
She's a murderer.
I mean she's the best striker.
Definitely top cup five best strikers
in the UFC. I'd say she Merck's chicks,
she Merck's him. She, she does some
horrible shit to them. Straight up. Yeah.
And so I think like when you look at
her, all right, before she gets into MMA,
she's a six time world Moy Thai champion.
That's her amateur background.
What she had to learn was
just take down defense,
defend yourself on the ground and figure
out how to get back up to your feet.
That's what cro cop had to
learn in pride. Yup. You know,
and I think when you
deal with someone like,
like Gennady Golovkin perfect example,
he's had like a fuck load of amateur
boxing fights. Sane man, saint amount.
You turn pro at like late twenties and
then he goes in the pros and these guys
just can't fucking compete with him
cause he's ready. He's so ready.
He says such another level.
His,
his technique is so sharp and on top of
that he's gets just this stupid punching
power that everybody's terrified.
Now would we see triple g, the guy,
the superstar, the is now if at 19 we
said, all right, you gotta go pro, boom,
get it. It's a good question. It's
tough right in. But the thing it's,
it's no one's fault. That's the empathy
of the UFC. It's just where we're at.
But for someone like Paige and Northcott,
like with, with Northcott, if I sat down,
I'm like, dude, they offer you a
top 10 guy. No Man, you're good.
I'm telling you bro.
I called,
I called out fucking Brock Lesnar
after I beat fucking Gabriel Gonzaga.
You know what I'm saying? It's like,
dude, what I wish so and been like, Yo,
shop chill man. This, this isn't,
this isn't a fucking sprint hair.
We will got to jog on my man.
The boxing systems like super established.
Know that's what I'm saying.
It's no one's fault. So long, no one's
fault. But everybody knows how to do it.
Like they know,
like when a guy gets to a certain level,
like you know Terrence Crawford
or something like that,
like you give the guy some tests along
the way, but you realize early on, okay,
you're dealing with a really talented guy.
This is what we're going to do.
We're going to slowly build them up with
some tougher and tougher fighters and
we're going to see where he's
at and we're gonna sit down.
Like that's why trade trainers
like Freddie Roach are so
invaluable because they
sit down,
they watch as these guys are fighting the,
Oh we got to get him with a guy with
a body puncher and we need to see what
happens. She gets pressured. We're
going to give him a test in this fight.
And what you're trying to do is
trying to build your fighter up.
Whereas what happens in MMA,
there's no like longterm structure and
there's no amateur structure that's like
comparable to what boxing has.
So it's really hard for people to get
built up to the point where they come into
the pro ranks with a very
high degree of skill.
Unless they come from a different
disap Breslin. I see wrestlers,
Damien Maia, Damien Maia,
fucking smashing people.
I mean Tammy Meyers Jujitsu is
terrifying. But what, what was,
he was a multiple time
world Jujitsu champion.
Shot Gray Jacques Perrey same
thing. Yolana same thing. Murderer,
Moy Thai champion, six
time world. You know,
I mean across the board there's so
many examples. Johnny Hendricks,
elite wrestler, Tyron
Woodley, elite wrestler.
I mean you can go down the list came
Alaska Daniel Cormier, wrestlers. Yeah.
You look at all the champs,
Ronda Rousey, judo Olympic. Yup.
Look at all the chances they have this
extent of amateur back and now you get
these other guys who don't have that
background. It's such a disadvantage.
No one's fault. No, I'm not
pointing any fingers at all.
I'm saying it's an issue in
the sport where it's tough man.
Because I was talking with, so, uh, I
think it was Kenny Florian. I'm like, man,
I'd love to see Northcott get
like eight fights in the UFC,
Merck people and get comfortable. And
we both agreed that there's, there's,
that's not gonna happen. Cause
he goes, he wins for neuro.
People are crying for a tau shot and
a reason for this is because of these
freaks, these one percenters that
everyone compares everyone too.
And that's like a Rhonda
Rousey just comes on the scene.
Merck and people are John Jones.
You're talking about most
people aren't like that man.
Those are the Lebron James of our sport
there most people in the sport at the
championship level or not like
Jen's what I'm saying or run,
but they're just not there.
They don't have that mental game.
You know what I'm saying? And then again
at the extensive competition background,
before you ever get to MMA, I think
you become like a champion already.
Like there's only a few guys
like Gustafson's a good example.
Gustafson was a good boxer.
You know he was an amateur boxer I
believe before he got into MMA. Correct.
But how much experience did we
haven't boxing? Did he? How much?
How many amateur fights of, yeah, I don't
think it's extensive. I don't think,
you know, he was like, oh, but he's
obviously like a hair off the champion,
you know a hair off the Jon Jones
fight here off the Cormier fight.
He wins that fifth round with Cormier
and he's a world champion and I agree and
it's heartbreaking. It's soup that, that,
that fight was super heartbreaking for me.
That fight was crazy for dustbin
cause it's like he lost a John and I,
this is loses the DC. He's
just, he's that guy man.
Did you see the picture he posted on his
Instagram today and I saw you between
this almost made me tear up. I know man.
Me Too. You know I love that guy. Yeah,
he's a great guy. But I love DC to
DC too. And that was a great fight.
But now you've got a
motherfucker waiting. Yup. John,
John and I don't know if
you've seen his Instagram,
but this motherfucker's motivated
and lift. He was whooping,
everyone's asked three weeks of training.
What now you're going to take coke,
Keno away from this motherfucker and
drugs and make them lift weights and I was
going to do a real camp. What the
fuck do you think's going to happen?
It's going to have a hard time cutting
weight. Nah, it's figure it out.
We'll figure it out.
What it was that he looked big,
didn't he? Jack looks like he's
getting ready for prison. Jack, Jack,
Jack Man. He's the best. He's the
best. As far as a light heavyweights.
Go for sure. I mean it's not close
though, Joe. You know what I'm saying?
Like I love DC, I fucking love DC. He
hit that guy. I love working with them.
I love being around them.
He is greatness at its finest.
And you know I have a son on the way.
DC is a god can point to and say
be like DC. He's a good example.
He's a great dude. He's done it the
right way. You can't say that about John,
right? Well right now you
can't. But Johnson, she's a
young guy. He's 27 years old,
right? Not that young. But the
thing is is with, uh, with DC,
he's like, he's like, he's like the
Phil Mickelson. You what I'm saying?
He's like Phil Mickelson of
golf where it's Tom Nicholson.
If tiger woods isn't exactly,
if tiger woods in the round,
we're all fucking wearing
fill mix and shoes and shit
right now. Really? Yeah man.
But Tiger Woods is that motherfucker.
He was that 1% better and
just beat them every time.
Socks to be Phil. I know, man
suck. He's still making bank.
He's still making bank
and people love them.
But it's a difference
between the UFC and golf.
You're not making that Jon Jones my place.
You can still have a private jet.
You should take down number two's
doing mind Ronda. It ain't fun.
You Ain't sipping champagne with Dana
white on private jet and number two,
we're Nike Shit.
The disparity between number one and
number two financially is fucking enormous
and fighting. Yeah. Fuck
yeah. It's fucking enormous.
It's like there's no other place
where it's bigger, you know?
Uh, yeah, I mean box and you could say
that a little bit. Well not really.
Cause you'll get to knowing who I
think is the biggest threat to John.
I just hear this rumble. Oh
I disagree. I think rumble.
If rumble gets his conditioning together
and I think rumble had a real hard time
in that Cormier fight. Um, but the,
the rumble that you see when
you saw him fight Jimi Manoa,
the rumble that like you're smiling.
Why are you smiling?
I'm smiling because you're like,
man,
if if rumble fucking got his cardio
together Bro and fucking got taller and
longer, his not on them. I'm not saying
that you're asking for and say that, well,
can't help Gustafson when he fought
gossips and he took us to send out in the
first round. True with a headbutt.
But the thing is, oh no, I love,
don't get me wrong.
We definitely did clash heads,
but I think his head got hit too. Exactly.
What happens if John Fights rumble?
What happens?
John takes him down.
Where's his us out and break
some of the second round?
Probably so midsummer Tkos wow. That's
how good John is man. And everyone's like,
oh, shops at Jon Jones. Not
hugger. Nah Man, he's very good.
I don't know what to tell you. It's
better than very good. Very good.
It's not even a good description.
That description. I agree. He's,
he's by far the best. Like there we
have everyone and then we have John.
That's how fucking good this guy is.
That's how bad he's beaten.
People would have John and the kind
of technique that mighty mouse has.
Fuck kind of took me on footwork. We're
going to ask you like a rumble match.
Like what if to have this time off,
John Jones comes out and
he starts fighting like Tj
Dillashaw. I'm like God, why?
Oh okay. What do you think
about this Tj Dillashaw thing?
Tj Dillashaw moved camps to elevation
team elevation in Colorado and you know
Uriah is a note. Well
understandably upset. You know,
I knew this far weeks cause he moved
to my head coach, my old head coach.
Oh really? Yeah. I can't say anything.
I don't want to break the news.
I'm not fucking surreal. Hawaii, someone's
coming with cash. Is that what it is?
Yeah, muscle farm. Jim is his pain.
The UFC fighters now. Ooh. And so yeah,
Tj is grown there and I tell you what
it does. Do you ready for this one?
It sets up your a t j Taco
bout our fucking countdown.
What Reebok kits for everybody.
What you imagine that?
Do you think they would do that 100%
they were agreed they would fight each
other now even more. Wow. Yeah. They've
said previously they would be down for it.
So what is the muscle farm deals at?
Some dude with oil money or something.
I don't know what those muscle phones,
a diamond factory style or no,
well I think what they're going to do
is cause they can't really be in the UFC
anymore, so they came up with
this plan. We're like, all right,
we'll sponsor fighters.
So we'll get all their Instagram and
social media and we can put our brand on
them that way. Oh really? Yeah.
Because since where all came, right,
like that's pretty smart. It's
smart. It's actually pretty smart.
I don't know how much to
pay them if it's smart,
but what makes smart to
get their social media?
Because I always thought about this
because let's say you give me whatever,
10 grand to wear a tee shirt for one night
for 30 seconds or you can swap it for
the year and all my fucking social
media training, I'm rocking your shit.
You can get way more coverage,
man. Well you can today too,
especially with a guy like Tj is super
popular or someone like Rhonda or you
know anyone who's like very
popular on social media.
You'll be social media savvy though.
A lot of guys aren't all,
you've got to have someone that works
with you and for you like a manager or
something like that and knows how to do
that shit. I used to hire a photographer,
Eric Williams, beast photographer,
and he come to my train camps.
He would take all these pictures and
send to me at night so I could post them
throughout the week. You would
post them on yourself? Yeah. Yeah.
Some people post all their shit
theirselves and some people,
like some athletes and even some,
uh,
like musicians you see like
posts posted by team cruise.
Tom Cruise has like a team that posts,
it's kind of lame though in its very lame.
Like I think it's dope that social
media allows people access to that they
normally wouldn't have. Yeah, that's what
I talked about, the personal interaction,
like whatever. Not Saying Dick
Pics. We know what I'm saying.
That's what it's supposed to be all about.
It's supposed to be all about like,
like if you get a tweet from me, unless
it's a, if you read a tweet from me,
unless it's from a youtube video, like the
youtube videos, when they get uploaded,
they automatically generate a tweet.
Yeah.
But that's just the title
of the Youtube Video.
There's no opinion in that or anything
like that. If you get opinions or, Hey,
this movie was fucking awesome. I ate
at this place. It tasted great. I chill.
That's amazing. 100% I don't
want to let anybody else do that.
My manager one time, I forget
which fight it was like, oh,
I'll tweet live free during your fight.
Like get the fuck outta imagine.
What do you kind of phrasing? Oh
Shit. He was saying, no, hell no, no.
What I was doing a show, they wanted
to take my social media, uh, safe.
I wanted to
take over my social media. You're bat
shit crazy. I never do that. I was like,
you gotta be, you gotta be on drugs. I
didn't let my girl fucking see me. What?
I'm not giving the Cineo Hall was a,
at the Ice House one night and I was
talking to him. It was after a show,
you know, he did the Arsenio Hall reboot
and uh, after they did it for a while,
it didn't work. Yeah. It didn't work
out or whatever. He's having fun.
He doesn't give a shit. But he was like,
I can't get my fucking Facebook back.
He's like, they have my Facebook. And
I go, well, you can't get it back.
He's so glad to give it to them when a,
I had to give control of my social media
fucked up. Yeah. You got to do that. Well,
Kevin Hart was talking about this, how
movies now. Uh, tell him like, hey man,
we need you to tweet out or
Instagram the movie. He's like,
that's on the contract. If you want that,
you gotta write, then that's extra money,
man. This is, this is a completely
different machine. W Well I'm,
I'm doing the movie.
You're pay me for my talent.
If you want me to promote on salt,
my social media that I've
built myself over the years.
You don't have to break
this into the contract.
That's interesting because I would
think that if he did something that he
enjoyed, he would want
people to see it so he would,
so I get it 100% I get it 100% I do.
But I also think like at his level,
he must be making so much fucking money
that like to say I want more money to
use my social media presence,
like what the social media presence is
really just going to do is alert his fans
to some movie that he's
watching his movie. Good.
Sometimes you gotta be careful of
social media and this is just me, right?
To compare it to Kevin Hart. Tom
Notch. Shit, I'm a grain of sand.
But when a company comes
in, he goes, whatever,
we don't work with the fighter
and the kid. I'm like, cool,
well the deals with me and Brian and like,
yeah,
but we want your social media to have me
post this stuff. Listen man, Fans Smith,
they hate that shit a motherfucker,
man.
They will always want to figure out
some way to weasel in always some way.
I always gotta be a way to get in
you. You know what? A lot of things,
a lot of people are experiencing this,
they're getting courted by these networks.
Like there'll be a network,
like a podcast network will come to them
and want to take a piece of the action
and get in return. They would provide
them with a certain amount of commercials.
Like really?
They're not providing anything.
But what they're doing is they're
saying by saying, you know, hey,
we'll provide you with some commercials.
We'll give you some commercial revenue.
But by saying that,
what they're really doing is they're
trying to figure out a way where they can
make money off of what you're doing.
Where you're doing it
completely independently.
Like right now what you're doing is
you're taking your stuff and you're just
putting it online.
Now you got to figure out that somehow,
some way someone that's eventually going
to figure out how to advertise that.
So what they're doing
is they're seeing like,
this guy is missing out on some money.
What I'm gonna do is I'm going to move in
here and I'm going to take some of his,
I'm going to give him some money,
but I'm going to take some of his money
where it doesn't make any sense that I
would make that money.
They're, they're like,
they're giving away 50% in some of these
cases with adjoining podcast networks,
the networks asking
for 50% and the people have done this.
It's like, what are you thinking, man?
It's crazy.
Don't give anyone 50% if you had
a radio show that makes sense,
like say if you were on a, you
know, CBS radio, whatever, just to,
just for a name to use, right? And you
had some sports radio show and they said,
listen, we're going to
syndicate your show. Uh,
we're going to bring your shell
across the country and well,
this is what we want.
We're going to get advertisers and we're
going to give you 50% of the ad revenue,
but you're gonna make a lot of
money. You'd be like, well, okay,
that sounds pretty good. It sounds like
a good deal, but the really they don't,
there's no channels that people
like automatically go to.
What people do is they get,
they download podcasts that they like,
whether it's radio lab or the fighter
and the kid or the Church of what's
happening now. They go to what
they like and then they get it.
Like the idea that you're just going to
tune into a dial 6:40 AM it's the ghost,
you know what I mean? Ghost morning
show, you know what I mean? Like this,
that that is like you have a distinct
location that people are accustomed to
going to,
they're going to go there.
It's like if you want ad space
on Santa Monica Boulevard,
well you know Santa Monica
Boulevard is a well traveled area.
If you put up a billboard up there,
it kind of makes sense.
You have to pay a lot of money. But if
someone says, dude, I got this billboard,
it's the middle of fucking desert. I want
a lot of money, I a fuck load of money.
I want to half of what you may,
50% is billboard up.
Can other people get to that billboard?
Yes.
They just have to get in their car and
they have to drive out to the desert.
And now about the money,
me and Calvin had a serious
discussion because you know, with, uh,
with the Shibori link yet, no
glory. Huh? We're trying to find it.
I supposed to going with the
podcast to better we, you know,
we're getting more sponsors,
advertise and stuff like that and we had
a major like corporate sponsor come to
us now.
I fancy myself when I was younger,
a couple of these products, especially
with cheese and ketchup only, right?
I loved a man.
I don't promote it now,
but I could buy a lot of with it, you
know what I'm saying? But Kevin was like,
absolutely not, man. He's like, I would
never tell people to buy this stuff.
You can't tell people to buy that.
You can't.
It's because it's the talking to
Callen and I ran some stuff by you.
It's just like, you can't do
that man, unless you love it.
Like if in and out burger came to me
and they wanted to offer a sponsorship,
I might have to fucking say yes.
I'll tell you right now is
the chick fil a comes to me.
What chick filet to hate gay
people. Do you know that? Hey Man,
I'm striking a chicken sandwich sandwich,
bro. Listen, they hate gay people.
Do they? Yeah. Jamie's like,
not anymore. Not Anymore.
Our push. It only worked on Jamie.
Jamie's you one like not anymore.
He interrupts apart. Not
Anymore. Don't even know that.
That's why. That's why. Damn. So I can't
eat chick flay anymore. That's crazy.
That's why those Goddamn promos with work.
That's why those,
they got me and Jamie says, I'll fucking
take a chicken sandwich right now. Oh,
they're very rude about the gay.
They spend money to try
to stop her marriage.
Yes. Been a big thing.
You've ruined my good job. It
doesn't matter. You can still eat.
It doesn't matter in the long run.
I like gay people because
you have stupid opinions.
Doesn't mean you shouldn't
be allowed to make money.
The problem is when they use no stupid
opinions seat there was super religious
and that's one of the things
that religious people,
they don't freak out about some
things that are in the Bible.
I like you very rarely see religious
people protesting against tattoos,
but in the Bible it's very clearly says
don't get tattoos. We're both fucked.
We're both fuck all superfoods.
Hilarious is there's a lot of people
that are super religious that fucking
tattoo religious shit on their body
that's not supposed to do that.
Like there's other stuff you're not
supposed to. Like if you go old testament,
you're not supposed to be eating pork.
You know you're not supposed
to be like an animal.
A split hooves that chews its own cud.
Like there's like we have rules like what
you're supposed to eat and what you're
not allowed to eat and there's a lot
of people that break those rules.
There's a bunch of rules about divorce
and his rules of out property and it's
like this is the rules that people
break in the Bible all the time,
but for whatever reason
with really religious folks,
that gay rule is the rule that they want
and forced. I think they give a fuck.
That's weird. It's weird. Like
my good friend Joe Rogan said,
maybe they're worried that
Dick's tastes delicious,
they're fighting off the gay for sure
that some of the gay fighting it off like
a vampire or putting garlic around her
neck and shit. It's also, I think they,
they, they think of gay. This is,
this is my amateur psychologist opinion
love to hear and I think some people
think of gay as being decadent and
indulgent and that this will lead to Slava
only behavior and too much partying and
fucking and guys suck sucking each other
off and come at each other.
And this is not conducive to a good
well-oiled society like Well Oiled Society
needs people to be buttoned
down and conservative.
That's why conservative people, they
tend to dress with like suits and ties.
They tend to let you know, like,
look, we're going to follow, I'm,
I'm down with this agenda. Okay.
God, guns, country. Um, uh,
I listen to country music. I got a
second amendment. They like, there's,
there's so cookie cutter in the way
they think that it's somewhere along the
line, like, God, there's so many people
that think along the same way. What is it?
Well,
this is an adoption of an ideology.
They're adopting a way to think they're
adopting this hardworking American blue
collar or you know, uh, conservative, uh,
religious God bless America.
Put your hands over your heart.
Let's all join in and in prayer.
God bless America.
Don't you think they're doing that so
they don't have to think for themselves?
There's a little of that. Yeah, there's
a little of that. And there's also,
you're subscribing to this ideology
that would most likely what you believe
it's,
it will most likely prevent people
from acting crazy and doing stupid shit
because they're going to follow God's
rules. So it'd be easier to raise kids.
Like it'd be easier
to have a family and just
bring them to church on Sunday.
And you say hello to the Wilsons
and everybody talks fake.
You're all talking like your strip
club Djs. Hello Mr. Wilson. Look, Hey,
you got a nice new sundown there,
Mr. Wilson. Jimmy, come on down. Ah,
listen man. People are looking at it
all wrong. I mean the more gay dudes,
the better more chicks for me,
man. Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
That's what I'm saying.
Well,
I think there's that and there's also
like this shit that I don't like.
I don't like discrimination. I don't
like it. I like any discrimination.
It drives me nuts. I agree 100% but in
both ways though too. Like I saw today,
there was a Seattle Yoga place that will
not accept white men or white people or
white men. I tweeted it earlier today.
Yeah, there's some Seattle. It is. Fuck,
do you hate money?
I'll,
I'll pull it up in a yoga class.
Like damn,
there's a lot of black people in there.
Well,
it's not that common and I don't
think, but some people, some of the,
some of the black folks enjoy the
yoga. Hey mine. I'm saying in general,
if you want to make money for
sure don't kick out white people.
That's their point. I think they
wanted something that's there is,
but to say that like that's, you know,
to say that white people can't come.
Like you got it Tammy, you're
missing the boat, you know,
it just doesn't seem to make any sense.
So when fucked you on your business plan,
well no whites allowed. It's whites. Yeah.
It's only the one we want people of color.
They want to exclude Caucasians in
Seattle. Yes. Kurt Cobain. Lynn,
you fuck it up man. Yeah, like
white people. Todd's
tough. Well, you know,
some people think that supporting
black people is not racist.
That just supporting university,
supporting black people's not racist
because black people have been oppressed
and that we,
we are doing is you're giving them place
where they can join in a community and
feel like they belong because they feel
ostracized from the rest of the world.
Especially in Seattle where everybody's
white problem with that kind of thinking
is, it's still the same thing I was
saying. White people can't come in.
It's like still the same thing saying
like black people can't come in that's
racist towards white people.
It's just racist.
Just make your fucking yoga place.
Just super and guidance to blacks.
Make it awesome, make it awesome
to everybody and you know, and,
and if you want more black people to do
it because you identify with those black
people,
reach out to them.
But to say that white people can't come
to your yoga class, that seems crazy.
Why would you not like people based on
how much melanin they carry it in their
skin or their ethnic origin of their
grandparents? It is fucking stupid.
It's fucking stupid. So stupid. If
you're white, stupid. If you're black,
it's stupid. It's stupid.
You're ignorant. Yeah.
So what religions Chick-Filet
Christian fucking a,
yeah, it is heartbreaking.
Yeah. Fuck you. Check.
There's a bunch of
Chick-Filet stuff online.
Like there's people that were boycotting
them and shit. That's crazy, man.
You know how to, I had
a cousin who was, uh,
basically beat to death because
he was gay. Whoa. Yeah, man.
So it's touched for me so
no more Chick-Filet for me even though
I love that fucking chicken sandwich.
Yeah,
see that's fucking crazy.
That's not because he's on a bus
and he was very like flamboyant.
They jumped him and basically beat him
to a pulp and he went home and died
later. Um, crazy. Right? Jeez.
Sahmri man didn't mean to fuck up. The
flow of the podcast trees was crow timer.
Denver Denver has on a public
transportation bus. Yeah.
A bunch of dudes jumped him for
them to find out who it was. Yeah,
they did catch up. Wow. What
happened to them? I'm not sure.
I remember I was in college at the
time. My Dad telling me, I was like,
what a fucking,
and I remember like when I was younger,
me and my brother are pretty close to him.
Him and his brother Nathan and,
and then then we know you do shit
and just fall out of touch by her.
And my dad told me, I'm
like, what the fuck?
I remember being mad that I couldn't
help them. It's weird, right?
The idea that someone would want to just
hit someone because they're flamboyant
because it, yeah, I know what the fuck
is wrong with the way they were raised.
So 100% what it is.
It's the way they were raised.
It's 100% if you were raised in a
community that didn't give a shit,
that would be like no big
deal. Like if if, okay, let's,
let's just say us, like all of us in
this room, like you, me and Jamie.
If we had our own little community and
one of us had a kid and then other ones,
another one of us had a kid and
we found out Jamie's kid is gay.
Do you think you would want your kid to
beat up Jamie's kid? He like, would you,
would you say you've
got to kick their ass?
Would you promote that kind of
thinking of it never wet. No Way.
It would never happen.
It wouldn't be possible.
But when you get enough fucking idiots
in a city and you get enough really
narrow minded,
bigoted people that have these shitty
ideas about other people's sexual
orientations or the way they
choose to wear their clothes,
or whether they choose to be goth or
whether it's anything, whatever it is,
if it doesn't,
it doesn't affect you.
Is it poisoning your pool
and they killing yours,
your vegetables and your garden,
like what's going on with
your upset and you're,
you're raising people
to have this fear of it.
And then they're interacting with other
people at school and they all have this
fear of it and they all want to let
everybody know that they're not like that.
And one of the best ways to let people
know that you're not like that is to
attack. People are like that
crazy man. Think about, uh, uh,
we had a transgender
person, I'm on our show, uh,
Caitlin back and she was saying, Kristin
Beck, Kristin Beck did save my men,
Kristen Beck.
And she was saying she'd locked down the
road and just group of five guys came
from behind his beat the shit out of her.
She said it happens all the time.
Transgender, it happens all, it's the
number one concern walking down the road,
getting beat up
and she was a navy seal.
He was a navy seal and gets her
ass. What? That's a crazy situation.
I had to be a navy seal,
full beard,
bad ass American killer out there,
I think.
I think it proves that they're
wired like that. You know what I'm
saying? Like no one chooses like, oh,
I want to take all this on and
it's especially today's society.
What y'all want to take us?
I want to be gay and have people
criticize him and all this shit.
Some people are certainly wired
that way. I think some are, yes,
and I think some choose, but I think
a lot people are born that way.
And you know what? Here's the other
thing though. The people that do choose,
that's their choice. I agree. Fun Man.
They're allowed to have that choice. Yeah.
It's like if you want to be Debbie
now, it's cool. You know what?
Whoever the fuck you want to
be. I don't give a shit. Again,
same thing if it doesn't affect me, if it
doesn't affect me, I don't really care.
I agree 100% the people that
do care though, they're scary.
They're scary to those folks.
To folks.
Someone that's transgender or someone
that's flamboyant or or black.
You're in the wrong place. You're black
or white. If you're in the wrong place,
you're white.
There's people that will beat the fuck
out of you because they feel like you got
a fucking easy hand cause you were
raised white. This will just crazy, man.
There's bad people in almost
every single demographic.
You're going to find people
that for whatever reason,
they got to where you are in
a fucked up way. Curve Ball,
not to change subjects,
but you think fucking humans are mother
fucker watched national geographic for a
little bit. Oh yeah. Mother
Nature is a motherfucker. Yeah,
till another level, man. Oh
yeah. Dude, is this live?
We got it. It's done now so we
can see the whole thing's done.
The entire event or getting ready to
start it back up at eight o'clock Pacific
Time. But we've worked Kelly West
coast, you can go back and watch this.
Let's watch it now so we can
start it whenever you want.
Bring it. Bring it. So, so,
uh, Joe Schilling already fought. The
whole thing was done. Wow, that's crazy.
It's only, it's not even eight o'clock.
Yeah, it's like a four hour event.
But Denver, it's in Denver. That's weird.
They're only an hour. Okay, well let's,
uh, let's see it because the main card
though, right? Or do you wanna watch
you do whatever the fuck we want.
Now we've got power. Jamie, Doug, um,
glory kickboxing. This is, uh,
this is this podcast going to morph
into a fight king penguin. Cause, uh,
my good friend Joe Schilling is
fighting on that card and, uh,
he's in the main event
against Jason Wellness,
who's a bad motherfucker
from Holland. Uh, two really,
really good kick boxers and both world
championship level. Joe Schilling,
of course. Uh, he's, he's been world
champion has been, he beat our Levin.
Who's a current glory world champion.
He won that fucking crazy four man
tournament. Crazy arts and 11 man.
Those guys, they had to fight it. Was
it three times or four times in a day?
Three times, right? Three times
that horrible kickboxing fights.
Just he had some rough, oh yeah, man.
The first one with a Simon Marcus
where it went to the fourth round,
they had a, they have three
rounds. They were a draw.
So they went to a fourth
round and Schilling knocked
him out in the fourth round
was fucking crazy. Ah,
that was round one. Two.
Can we get some volume,
Jamie? I don't think, Gloria,
what do you want me to start
it? This is one of the early ones
is just the whole four hour event.
I got to figure out where. Oh, right.
Does Christ. That's a lot of key.
Let's get a, let's get this, uh,
this screen over here and give
us the data of who is that?
Do that with this? I can't, I'm
using the computer for the video. Oh,
that's right. You're going
to eight and 12 cause. Okay.
Kevin [inaudible] strand a lot of Denver
boys on this card. Being in Denver,
this is a tough place to fight.
Denver can be tricky when you're a,
well not like Mexico City.
Mexico City is the trickiest of tricky.
That's why it's going to be interesting
to see the Cain Velasquez we're doing
reading jail. Yeah. Are they
going to do it in Brazil?
I don't think that that's confirmed
exactly from pretty sure it's confirmed I
fee. I feel like you would
know better than me. Well,
I don't think it is honestly like it is.
I talked to Javier Melendez how long ago?
Javier Mendez the other day.
Okay. It's a couple of days
ago, man. I thought it was an,
I hear Mauro run Nelo.
I liked his commentary on
these two events. He's great.
He's gotten so good from doing showtime
boxing during the Floyd Mayweather
fights. He's really, really, he's
excellent. I love the showtime crew.
This feller with the tattoo on his
back with us in Denver at grudge. J Ho.
I liked that tattoo. That's dope.
It's American as fuck. Sawn super.
Got a Goddamn John American flag.
Uh,
you were talking about nature being
a motherfucker watching the, the, uh,
oh my God, I have to turn it off, man.
I don't do well seeing the animals
die shit. Horrible Shit Man.
I saw this mountain coat
can chase by a snow leopard.
Snow Leopard chase him all
the way down the cliff.
Grabbed him by the ass
about the anus first.
W key got away instead of dealing with
death in the fucking snow leopard full
just jumped in the river,
died. Commit suicide, Babe.
Baby dare just born in this fucking
wild pack of dogs is coming.
The mom pieces out. This baby
deer can barely stand eight done.
It's intense.
Nature does not fuck around.
More than half of all the Moose
and deer that, uh, get killed.
And Canada, uh, they get killed right
after they're born by bears. Dude,
I was depressed as fuck coyotes,
shit like that right after they're born.
You know, that's a big thing
too about grain. You know,
a lot of people think that they want to
live a life where they're not involved
in any death. And, uh, that's,
that's a noble, you know,
you don't want to cause any
animal suffering. I get it.
I totally understand that idea. Even
though I hunt and even though I eat meat,
I totally get why they feel like that.
But there's a reality to commercial
grain and one of the realities commercial
grain is, you know, those,
those things that combines those
things that they turned up there,
they cut the wheat with those
things are indiscriminate.
They kill everything that's on the crusher
rabbits and they kill a lot of fawns
too because Fonz, when they're
young, when they're newborn,
what they like to do is stay put.
So if there's anything common with they
do is they just stay put and they kind
of hide and they get ground up by the
combined. It's, it's super common.
Rabbits,
Rodin's ground nesting birds,
all of them get ground up and those
things, there's almost no way,
unless you're growing your own food
and you growing your own vegetables and
you're there for the whole process,
you make your own compost.
There's almost no way to leave. No
footprint. How about that Lq shot.
You just posted it today with the
deal. That thing. I shot it with it.
Wednesday morning. 5,000 pounds. A
thousand pounds. Enormous. A big animal.
A giant animal. I'll show you another
picture that's even more crazy of it.
What'd you hit? Shoot him with a bazooka.
Bone Arrow. Straight Bodell yeah.
Yeah man. A lot of work went into that.
A lot of skill of the bone now. Yeah.
The SPEC for shoot Arrow bar.
Well it's uh,
it's coming from a guy who was the
different shirts that you get a look at.
Huge hanging off of a, uh,
a tree. We're cleaning it.
You kind of get a sense
of how big it really is.
That's how he got into a truck to huge.
Yeah.
He's probably a thousand pound animal.
It's a norm and they get bigger.
There's some, some of the like 12, even
1400 pounds, a really enormous ones,
especially at [inaudible] ranch.
And by the way,
they're not even the biggest moose
are even bigger than them. Moose,
her giant dude. There's Moose in the
Yukon that are 1800 pounds. Dude.
That thing is fucking huge.
Imagine something twice as big as that.
That's a moose in the Yukon,
literally twice as big.
Then what do you guys hang it then?
You and your friend? Well first you,
you back the truck to it and then they'd
put it into the back of a pickup truck
and then we, um, took it to a cooler,
like a walk in cooler and then you,
then the real work begins.
You start,
it's when you get your hands on
ordering it and taking pieces off of it.
And you brought it home. I
brought most of it home. Uh,
some of it is at a butcher shop and it's
getting a turn into sausages and shit.
And when you shoot some elk sausage,
sausage,
high protein son might wake up in the
middle of the night with Predator dreams
though. When you shoot a thing like
that, how long did it take for it to die?
That was pretty instant. There
was a, it was a perfect scenario.
It was dead within a minute.
But you know,
that's one of the things
about the discipline of, uh,
of getting better at getting
better at dealing with the nerves,
getting better at aiming,
making sure your archery skills are
on point or your rifle skills for that
matter. Like rifle, you could injure
an animal rifle hunting too. Super,
super important that you
work really hard on it.
It's also just so fucking nerve wracking,
really. God, this is my thing though,
with that fucking giant elk.
If let's say you nick it,
you miss or whatever and you it had
your way. It's your ass. Really? Yeah.
You're fucked. And if it
decides to, Oh yeah, I'll slap
the shit. Oh you. Thank you.
Well, does she the antlers? I did
see the antlers. Dude. It's a tree.
It's Kinda trail behind a tree, bro.
I don't get it. All right, so Tom,
if you could go behind a tree,
you could pull it off,
but keep going around the table.
If you got stuck in an open area and some,
for some reason he got to you
first and getting fucked up,
you're getting fucked up.
It happens.
It's not that common because
they usually scared of people.
They try to get the fuck away from you.
What really happens is more with bears,
with bears, it could really
happen for sure. And Moose right,
aren't Mussa gross of a shit. Well,
they're definitely aggressive if you want.
If you wound them Rinella, Steve. No,
my friend from that show meat eater,
he got run over by a fucking moose
on a show dude. It was crazy.
Did he told me about it after
the fact that I watched on TV,
like the way he described it, it sounded
crazy. But then watching it you're like,
oh my God, he shot the Moose, the Moose
went down, he thought the Moose was dead,
came up on it and then the Moose got
up and he went, oh shit, he's alive.
And he went to shoot him again and
the gun misfired which is so rare.
It's so rare that you pull the
trigger and nothing happened.
So he had a re re chamber another round
and in the process who is moose comes
behind him and sends him flying and
there was blood on him and he couldn't
figure it out. If it's his blood
or the moose is blood. He's like,
he's feeling his body.
See if he's been punctured.
And we got nailed by a big ass animal.
And for the Moose one for the Moose.
The Moose get away. No, of course. No,
no, no, no. My Buddy Ryan was there.
Ryan Callahan put a bullet into him.
What happened? We lose our, our feed.
Yeah, let's move ahead. Anyway. Yeah.
But um, so, you know,
just nature being dangerous.
Nature, being a ruthless.
We're a, we're so, I'm
so insulated from it.
That's why people have these beautiful
ideas of what a, what animals aren't.
How people fit into the food chain.
We're so used to getting our dirty
work done for us. This is true.
You got to bring me some time, man.
Oh, I got you. You want to come?
I'm sending Everlast out.
Everlast uh, he totally unrelated.
They didn't even know that I got
back from, from a hunting and he, uh,
sent me a text saying that he wants to
hunt and he wants, he wants to, you know,
find someone that'll take him through it.
And so, uh, I set him up with this guy,
Brian Meadows who, uh, was, uh, my, uh,
guide this past weekend or
one of my guides. And He, um,
one of the guys that works there,
there's like a bunch of like really good
guides that work at this one ranch and
uh, he's going to, uh, do like a
thing with him where he takes him out,
shows him how to shoot,
shows them how to you in the rifle
and then they're gonna go hunt pigs.
How long is this parable? Days?
Yeah. Well you don't like pigs.
Some, a little more danger.
You know what I'm saying?
You ever see a wild boar before? Dude,
they have wild boars on this ranch,
Texas tusks, no tone ranch. It's up north,
north of here, like an hour and a half.
Not far at all.
They have some photos.
I'll show you some after the show
received bills while the war's not fun.
Wild boar sound like monsters.
We were,
we were there the first
time I was ever there. Uh,
we were passing by this
really thick, these thick, uh,
grasses like high tall
grasses but weeds and grasses.
Like it was like four or five feet tall.
He couldn't see inside of it,
but you knew there were pigs in there.
And so we're walking down this dirt road
really slow and quiet so they don't,
they don't even know were there and
we hear them fighting like what?
It sounds like there's demons in
there tearing each other apart.
They fighting for some reason why
they're making all these crazy bore
noises. I was freaked out, dude.
I was definitely freaked
out by wild boars.
Did you see that movie or that
TV show? Game of Thrones? Yeah,
the fucking king got killed by a wild
boar. Giant boy until he got them.
I've seen like one damn, uh, to
just got dropped another demo.
We don't even know who's fighting,
who's the guy in the orange. Trump's,
that's the Denver kid can understand
them. Train. This is over.
Yeah. Dammit. My kids. Good little
hairy armpits though, Huh? Yeah. Yes.
Those up, man. Let's hold. Cool. I
like that. Was his Bush look like?
Probably ridiculous. See
that Dick. So you see that?
You see that doctor in the ring?
They just show him with glasses.
Check this story out. There's
bang. There's bang though.
That doctor on the left.
Check this out. Oh, so he was in
trouble right now? No, not at all. Okay.
Horrible story though. Jamie. Do
we have any more of these things?
We have regular coffee, don't we?
Didn't you make regular though?
Are you still in my system? Coffee? No. No
butter. No bullshit. Yeah. So that doctor,
right? He goes on a family vacation
wife, three kids. She bit life,
three kids and fucking Subaru, outback,
whatever the hell it was. They go,
he's in Wyoming. They go,
don't drive. There's a flash
flood warning. He goes off.
Fuck it. We can get through. It drives
flash. Flood warning through this thing.
Takes the car over.
Entire family dies separate home.
Oh my God. Three kids. Three little
kids and the wife. Oh my God.
I'm just full of fucking who brought
don't news first. The good news bear.
Hey Man, I didn't know they were going
to show the fucking guy. Oh, Jesus.
You didn't have to tell the
whole story. It's intense, right?
That's pretty intense. So then, uh,
Shane car, when a bunch of us did,
or like a fundraiser form, ugh.
Horrible men. Natures are cruel,
cruel bitch. Nature does not
give a fuck. We found an elk,
the cop murked by another
elk. Dammit. Elton crime.
That's rare, right? Nope. We're all
super common. They fight to the death.
Sometimes they stab each other
with their giant antlers.
That's what the amateurs are
for. But occasionally, you know,
sometimes they just get scarred up and
to get you have cuts on their head button
shit on TV. Maybe rams. Cause they,
they tangle antlers like deer and
elk and Moose. They tangle antlers.
That's the angle antlers are for,
I'm trying to suck on those
antlers. So that eight, oh, was it IGF
one or some shit people were doing.
You want the velvet? Yeah. I want to
suck on that velvet. The velvet deer,
velvet and elk velvet. Uh, it was like
a real hot property or one year ago.
It was such a hot property that
what they were doing was it
to see via the, um, the, uh,
there were farms in Alberta where
they were growing this shit.
They were growing elk just to use
their velvet. And then the process,
for whatever reason,
it became less and less
valuable to people and the, uh,
amount that's that Stevia is super weak,
just pour a bunch and they're like,
it's sugar. I was like the worst Stevia.
Jamie got it from the dollar store.
Dammit Jamie. But um, um,
so this guy spent like a million dollars
investing in this elk farm thinking
he's just going to cash and on his
deer of else spreading shit. Yeah.
From the elk and uh,
eh,
nobody gives a five idea while
he thought it was going to be
gangbuster business,
but the business dropped.
Is this the same guy that opened up a
fucking all black yoga studio in Seattle?
Oh, those poor fox. They're going to get
attacked and attacked online to them.
They showed this fool's record set
three and five. That's a weird thing.
Like where
that's bang on Bang, Bang, Bang on bang.
But he's that guy that um,
this guy tough to man the guy's three
and five are they said he's tough.
The Guy Bang Bang on
bang is the guy that um,
what is his name?
Who did he fight?
He fought somebody recently on a really
good fight. I'm trying to remember,
but he fought Raymond Daniels and Raymond
Daniels hit him with that spinning
flying ThreeSixty side kick
to the face of it. Yeah,
he jumped with the front leg side kick
like flying side kick and then he touches
you with that and spins and clipped him
right on the Chin and send them to la La
land on banks. Tough as fuck man.
The other guy I think is from La,
I think he's a, uh, he might
be from the yard I think.
Oh Shit. Nice knee. How much of these boys
make? Not that much money, man. Did. Why?
I'm sure shilling makes good money.
She'll be making good money in
the light being the headliner.
So anyone know or no, I don't know
what guessing. I'm just guessing.
You know what I just root for for glory.
I love kickboxing.
I've always loved kickboxing.
I love,
I love Moitai to let's I
root for lion fight too.
I almost what? I almost watched
every line fight every glory. Uh,
I watch every one of these. Me
Too, man. I don't miss much.
Especially the lion fight.
I like lion fight cause they use elbows.
I like lion fight a lot of time.
There's a lot of uh,
new guys on there and they'd
go for fucking broke man.
They seem to get a lot of like high level
Thai guys to correct and they fly him
in against like an American and show
no one. You seen the wad wildfire.
Jesus Christ,
he's national.
We've said it before that tiff time bomb
man a little. She's a very good teacher.
Some takedown defense.
You got one on one 15.
She's very enjoy that
lady's reverse Joanna,
she talked some shit about joining a
stand up. She said she was basic. Ooh,
basic bitch. They say go, we got to
get me trying to start something.
Oh, what do you have in diet
coke? Bitch basic bitch, bitch.
Stupid basic bitch. What'd you got up?
Fucking blueberry muffin with your coffee,
your basic bitch. It's her.
Anything worse to got a basic bitch.
If you're a girl, ruthless man,
it's well being called anything,
you know, but something
happened. Someone to find you.
But having someone like limited
defining you like that define unit.
You're limited. It's
hard. It's hard out there.
Still worse. Yeah man. It's
worth it to have your coffee.
Basic pitch book for a girl though.
Does a girl have to be more than basic
or she could. She'd be basic in hot.
That's tough.
Well see the hot factory?
Well yeah man. It's like that's, that's
nature right there. That is man nature.
One hate on it. And h likes
that hip to waist ratio. We do.
Nature's a big fan of Teddy's.
They're universally accepted.
It's not like there's a place in the
world where you have perfect set of tests
and people go, Ugh, get those out of here.
There's not a single country where
men don't look at juicy tits and go,
oh yeah, check. Totally useless to sit
on it. They don't do anything for you.
They don't increase pleasure unless
you're fucking, unless your titty fucking,
but you see them and your brain goes,
oh yeah,
it's nature.
There's bags of fat,
bags of fat with nipples that you can
suck on and they gently put in if they
have weight to them and the girls riding
you and you could like hoist them up
and suck on them. Like, oh,
everything gets so exciting. Why does,
and they do nothing.
They did nothing.
Nature Nature wants you to have a wife
and that's some big old titties so that
when your kids need breast milk,
this,
these titties or down to
produce big ass titties,
dudes that need big hips and fat and
asses and legs that looked like they can
run and jump. So you have kids that
inherit those traits? Yeah, man.
If you see a girl with like
weird hips and her ass is flat,
she walks with a stumble. You're like,
oh no, no, no. Immediate basic bitch.
I call it the it beat it with your
flat feet. Flat feet, flat ass.
Why can't you walk straight flat outside?
There's nothing worse than a flat
ass. Yeah. I don't mind if a girl,
a small breasts now we'll figure it out.
A lot of really hot girls that have small
breasts money. We'll figure that out.
Well, it's funny you don't, man, if he
gets serious enough, I'll cover this.
What'd you though? Would you want to
or would you write a hundred person
shop sponsor. You take
that over, uh, over what?
What would you take though if you had
the option between a girl with a really
nice acid,
nice legs and small natural breasts
or a girl is pretty dejected ass.
Pretty decent legs,
but big fake titties ass all day because
I can fix the titties because they
haven't, they haven't. What if she
didn't want to fix the titties?
What if that's a deal breaker going to
have to move on? Wow. I'm just kidding.
I'm not kidding.
I just said if you've seen my girl,
she's from planet Pluto.
But the thing that's so fucked up,
but the thing is they haven't figured
out a good way to make asks implants like
you see a fake ass worst thing you've
ever seen. There's a difference, man.
There's a difference. The the
ass thing, it's like there's an,
there's like various factors,
right?
The titty factor is like
the nurturing factor.
Like that's the attraction is
that she'll be good at nurturing.
She has breasts for, but the ass
thing is like an athletic body.
It's like an exciting body.
Oh, I'm banks can't fucked up.
This dude who's three and five is teeing
off bitch on form five. You Basically,
oh yeah, he's foreign five tonight.
Five motherfucker. I liked the fact,
oh damn. I liked the fact
he's done. Done, done, done.
I liked the fact that they throw knees.
I do like that.
I'm glad they could still throw knees
and I think there are a lot of hold only
with one hand though. That's
it. His fights over. He's
taking it. He's done. Done.
Yeah. Let's go ahead and call us the day.
Everybody. Wow. He's standing or not.
We're Sni. I've ever seen Overeem.
Fujita. Yeah, there was that one.
I thought I'd killed him over and
killed again. Overeem to share it.
You ever see that one? Yes. To
share with the crazy dreadlocks man.
He hits with a knee and that dude is like,
he went down like he was Danny Fajita Day.
He was in the ring. Like there it goes,
faces in cave like you so
fucked up and that's Uber Rain.
We're not talking about normal.
Oh No. Like, oh, I don't
know if he's going to win.
We're talking about fucking
Japan over rain. Well, Japan,
Japan over him. Once he hit that
like k one grom pre heavyweights.
Yeah.
Fuck it.
Don't they dug up Nazis that
had special science just sued
shit. Brought it into the
lab. Well, this dude, uh,
four five. What is his
name? Do we know Jamie?
Good for him, man. You know, I've seen
this dude fight before. He's good.
That was like a big victory. That was
very impressive on bank. Took a beat.
Is that Dr. Brooks like Irish
fear got his ear pierced? Well,
maybe he's wiling out.
I'm sure he is.
100 hunter were chains on his
neck to the back. Chest. Palmer.
Hey, he's trying to make it happen. How
dare you? How dare you? How dare you,
dude. If I was like Joe
Rogan, scrooge McDuck rich,
I'm hiring scientists to build
fake ass is like no other.
I don't want to fake gas though.
That's like the flat earth. Tough life.
It's hard out there and you don't breed.
Just like what happens if you know in the,
in the wild,
what happens if you have unfavorable
characteristics, you get ate
up as first. That's how it goes. Oh, but
we'll make it prevent way of the world.
It's the way of the world.
But how you can't prevent that with
a piece of plastic. You can wave.
They're going to be rented. No, no, no.
You can give the illusion
that you preventing it, but
you know that ass is fake.
It's the same thing with lips. Lips, you
can't do to live. So he did the tits.
They found a crazy loophole with
tits and it works. They snuck in,
they snuck in with a tid implants
and everybody's like, well, hey,
we could do it there. We could
do it everywhere. But you can't.
It only works on women's tits. Doesn't
work on guys tits, dude, I'm not maggots.
10 implants. Women's lips. Girls don't
want that shit. Some women's lips that a,
I'm not mad at them. They get a couple.
We're going to talk off. Here we are.
We really is. Nonsense. This is craziness
bro. Who is this young gentlemen here?
I've seen him fight before. Not a full
crowd yet is this isn't the main card,
is it? No, no. Robert Thomas Geoffery.
If this is early in the
card is early 22 yolks.
My boy and the ride is jacked
at 34 I think he's flourishing.
Makes Sense though, right?
I he's flexing a hundred.
Got a beautiful beard though in a Mohawk.
That's rare in flavors.
Fresh off the set of 300 okay.
I think they're going to fix it
with gene therapy. Dude, that's,
that's the real fix.
This plastic they shove in your ass and
make your ass stick out isn't fooling
anybody. The same thing with your lips
like why are your lips bigger than all the
surrounding tissue? That doesn't make
any sense. They fool man with the lips.
They full may bro might be a
little bit basic. You know what?
I might be a basic bitch.
I like lips.
I think a girl's lips are like really
important when you're kissing a girl
hockey over many of reasons,
but if you're feeling like
a rubber thing under there,
I can't think that that would be good.
It just looks weird to not if it's done
right. Okay. Maybe I'm, maybe I'm wrong.
There's a lot of state doctors out there.
I hope so,
but I think that the what what
you're seeing now is like this.
It's the beginning.
Like when they were,
when they thought that they could put
like feathers on people and have him jump
off cliffs and it didn't work out or not.
Well, eventually it became an airplane.
Like somebody had,
they keep saying like trying with that
thought until they got it right and now
you know,
you get on a virgin airlines jet to Boston
and you fucking got the beautiful red
widget lighting.
You have yourself a champagne.
It all started from some asshole
with a bunch of feathers.
You thought it could jump
off a cliff. True. It has to
start there. And right now,
these girls that you're looking at with
these crazy fake lips and these plastic
plates in their asses,
they make their ass out.
What they are is the dude with the
feather jumping off the cliff and they're
unfortunate demise and they get tangled
up in the branches of the tree below.
Their unfortunate demise will make
people innovate. True. I'm with you, man.
It's fine. I hope I'm around for that.
What do we got here, Jamie? Oh Damn. This,
this dude from Canada just landed
a beautiful knee to the body.
So we're watching these
fights. Um, if you're watching
these at home, you might
not even be able to, uh,
there's no way you're going
to sync this up, but we'll,
we'll try to sync it up when once we
get to Joe Schilling, stitch him up who,
uh, is a little bit later on the
card. Once we get to stitch them up,
we'll tell you exactly what time it is
and you could sync this thing up later.
This fight him.
I think mcnichols arena,
that's the old school man
isn't super old school.
One of those few of these was that
team Miss Denver at all in any way?
You know what, now?
Wow. It's weird, right?
I go back and I feel like
I'm in a country Western man.
Denver people are going to eight me,
but it's whatever, bro. It's true.
It's my favorite spot. Oh,
there's some great spots in.
Have great family and friends, but you
could not pay me to move back there, man.
I will never leave.
My number one choice comedy
works outside of a California,
Colorado is my number one choice,
either evergreen, evergreen, boulder,
or Denver. He goes, my three
spots that nature. Shit. I
love the paint. Don't shit,
Bro. You don't like, how
would you kill some shit?
But then I want to go
back to Marina del Rey,
jumping my Porsche and do some weird shit.
As I've gotten older,
I appreciate nature way more and more.
I feel like it's like
something that I just didn't,
I didn't appreciate it enough
until I got older. Like a,
I think when I was younger I was always
concentrating entirely on doing whatever
I'm trying to do, whether it's
fighting or going, getting into comedy,
getting my career in line, you know,
like becoming a professional comedian.
And then, you know, all the
things that I've ever done.
I've always been concentrated more on
them than anything else. More on the,
and then as I got older I started,
well, what brings me pleasure?
I started thinking like, what
do, what do I enjoy being around?
And one of the things that I enjoy
being around was beautiful nature,
likes to see a mountain.
Like I remember going to, um,
Jesus, I don't know where the fuck it
was. Like one of the first I got us,
you know what to hear. One of the big one
was going to the aspen comedy festival,
man. I went to the Aspen comedy
festival, I want to say like 2002,
I think it was like 2002. And, uh,
I was in Aspen and I was driving with
this dude who worked for the festival and
he was telling me how he has
elk off of his back porch.
I didn't know elk screamed.
I did. I had no idea.
I didn't know a goddamn thing about
grain back then. And they scream elk.
Bugling you never heard of elk? Bugling
I recorded some of it from my trip.
You, this is real shit that happened this
week. Elk make it easier to kill you.
They scream. Oh, they don't, they're
not easy to kill it, man. There,
especially with a bow, they're hard.
But what it is is that they, um,
they're trying to get some pussy so they
call out to women or to let them know
that they're the right to fuck.
And they also call it the men.
They're ready to challenge them
and they, uh, they do battle.
Like I'll show you some pictures
of this dead one that they found.
It got stabbed up.
He got murked by some other
fucking bull and they're big.
These are a thousand pound animals.
Just like the you killed bigger
as big as the one I killed.
Thanks fucking the one. The one that died
was bigger than the one I kept bigger.
Who killed him? Some bad ass.
Bitch. Listen to this though.
This is what it sounds like. Oh,
it sounds like a grown man yelling.
Hello Sir. I'm here.
It is. Listen. No Sir.
You hear that? That's the
guide. Trying to call them.
He's making like a cow call to listen
to the sound that they make when they
respond.
It's like a like a monster
that, that high pitch shit. That's the
guy making the call. Now listen to them.
Okay.
You hear that almost
sounds like Ortho whales.
Okay.
Damn.
They scream at each other like that.
Now really loud one was the guide
right next to us with the call.
That's one of them screaming
dad. That was an ALC.
Oh, weird. Right. Then do you listen
to that and find out where they're at?
Just destroy him.
Well,
you got to sneak up on them when
you should know where they're at.
He sneak up on them and then you hide
behind stuff when you make calls like a
cow. So they think they're going to get
some pussy fucking basic bitch elks.
Too easy. Become screaming too
when they come towards you.
That's one of the most nerve
wracking parts about it. Oh yeah.
Cause I think there'd be your hook.
Exactly. Dick out there. Like, what's up?
Will they come?
They come all over themselves.
They piss all themselves
and come all themselves.
They look at their whole under suicide.
When you find them in the running.
Is this covered with like common pis?
They're all wet.
They're looking for a good time. They're
just, they're partying. Fuck man.
You guys just, Hey, what's up?
Oh, raging boner, ted, bro.
It is rude. But uh, it's also
hot mountain lions fun too.
When we were in Colorado, one
of the guys I was with, uh,
told me that they had found this mountain
lion on top of this elk and they found
it by following the,
uh,
the path that it took once a drag the elk.
So what he found was like you could see
the mountain lion footprints and then he
could see the elk footprints
and then they collide.
And then there's no more mountain line
footprints because the mountain lion is
riding the elks back.
Can you get this 1200 pound elk in this
150 pound cat is on its back biting its
neck and it runs like 102 hundred
yards with this cat on its back.
And then it piles up and
then the cat eats it.
They catch the cat on top of this thing.
You know what man?
I think the reason why I don't get down
with nature and mountains and stuff,
cause I grew up in Denver man. So I was,
I was going camping all the time. Uh,
I was shooting arrows when I was
young and shit. So I'm over it man.
I love the ocean. I can't get enough of
the ocean. Yeah, see that's it. You're,
you're experiencing the new nature.
So then the next, I mean the ocean is,
I rented a place in Malibu for like
three months this last summer and uh,
I would wake up every morning just
looking at that water going, wow.
I feel like there's nothing
crazy. Love it. It's crazy.
It's a crazy view and it's a,
it's a morphing view.
Like in the daytime it's inviting and
it's night. At nighttime it's terrifying.
Terrifying.
And that that's the only difference.
The only difference is you can't see.
Yeah. Would you ever live in Malibu?
I don't know if it's wise to
buy a home next to the water.
I don't know if it's wise to spend
several million dollars for a house that's
stuck in the sand right in
front of the lip of the ocean.
You want to talk about basic bitches?
Like are you not paying attention to
the entirety of the human history that's
been recorded about the changing of the
earth's atmosphere and about how the,
like you find cities that are underwater,
there were like Roman cities and
shit and other underwater. Why?
Why are they underwater? Well, they're
underwater because there's the,
the ocean moves expense. It's not stuck
there. It's not going to stay. Exactly.
If you're looking for investment
2000 years from now, yeah,
probably don't buy a house in Malibu.
However, for when you're alive,
you should be fine, Joe. You know
what I'm saying? Yeah. Maybe,
but maybe not. I can almost guarantee.
How about fun? What happened in Japan?
That shit could happen in
Malibu in the day and Indian,
you need need day. I have a friend
who lives in Pacific Palisades.
It's got a nice sweet
spot up a hill and uh,
I could want you to live by the water.
You've got a lot of money. He goes,
so nominees tsunamis. I go, really?
He goes, yeah. He goes, they happen.
He goes, they might not happen, but they
happen. And when they happen, guess what?
What are you gonna hear?
You can hear a horn mill the night
I sleep with a sound machine.
I have a sound machine
next to my bed place.
Sounds like birds and shits or get
sleep. That's what he said. He goes,
I'm not drowning in death. God
Damn, that's dark. I mean, fuck bro.
I live right on. You know I
live on the marina. The way
they sold me. They're like,
you have a tsunami comes thing. I said,
really? There? Yeah, I'll take it tilts.
I'll take it, save all that
shit. It's going to fill up
with water. [inaudible] up,
man. The real tsunami, the
real bad motherfuckers.
It's going to drown it.
It's going to be all under water,
like the idea of like 500
feet of water up and down.
That's nothing in the history of
the world. That shit's happened.
Thousands sometimes role.
Just how you're not a real estate fucks.
Say I'd be like,
look,
what you really want to do is you want
to be on top of the mountain looking down
and you want to have a raft up there.
Yeah, man. You got to have like Noah art.
I don't know if that's a reason not to
live by the beach. No beach town side.
It's still awesome.
If you were like super baller,
like Richard Branson type character,
you really ideally want to houses.
You want a house at the top of
the mountain. Now you want three,
you want a house at the
top of the mountain,
you want to fat place in the city
and then you want a spot on the wall.
You want to do that.
If you're going to be a fucking super
baller scrooge McDuck style. Yeah you,
but you got to have like,
you know,
fucking Shell oil type money
if you want to do it right.
A lot of money and having three mansions.
I'm not talking about mansions.
Maybe have a condo downtown like a
dope ass penthouse. That's a good move.
Yeah man.
I'm a,
I'm not a big fan of living downtown
because the God damn traffic,
but you know, it's tough man. It's brutal.
It's brutal to get downtown's row
ruthless. But I would never live down,
but it's kind, Kinda dope. Like,
like you could walk around downtown now
and it's like he's cleaning up and ls
putting a ton of money into it. They
want it to be like the hot new hot spot.
So it's a good place to buy it.
They got to kill bums.
There's only one way they're
going to have to kill some bumps.
What the fuck you sit. We're kidding
folks. We're not kidding. Well,
I'm not going to have crappy value.
We don't have to get rid of them. No,
I'm just kidding. This guy, first of all,
this dude from Canada
is a mother fucker dude.
The guy in the black shorts is he from
Canada? 22 two and he's bad ass man.
This is a tough fight that other time
that the other two is taking some serious
body shots. Third round here.
Um, I just think that uh,
the bump thing is, it's all
bullshit aside. You know,
obviously I don't think you should
kill him, but when you look,
you stop and look at it.
If it's a horrible indictment of how
flawed our current system of community is,
that our community allows people to get
so disenfranchised, there's an entire,
like a whole ecosystem of people
in downtown La. I get that.
I look at it and they make me sad when
people don't know what we're talking
about.
Like if they'd ever seen skid row,
like these people that are
listening to us like, oh,
you're being so mean about homeless
people. It's is a different thing.
It's like walking dead.
But imagine all the zombies in one place
and they will eat your dick off for
crack. It is really crazy. It's,
it's one of the craziest things you'll
ever say that there's a ton of them in
Venice to man. Oh yeah. Tom In Venice.
Yeah. They get uncomfortable too.
And you're out those uh, Venice beach
spots when they gather and you know,
they want money from tourists
so they start bagging. Yeah.
It's, it's rough. Well,
it was a lot of crazy people.
That's really what it is.
It's a mental health issue that gets
thrown around a lot for everything. Right.
I think some of our mental health, I think
some were just like, fuck, fuck it man.
Yep.
I think also though saying fuck it though
is a bit of a mental health issue or
is it just called giving up?
I think even that is mental health.
Like don't you think it's
healthy to have good friends?
It's healthy to be a good friend.
It's healthy to be in love.
It's healthy to be fulfilled
by your pursuits in life,
whether it is a, you know,
your artistic pursuits or
athletic pursuits or your
career pursuits, those are,
that's a health issues. It's like
isn't it healthy to exercise? Right?
That's a physical health issue actually.
He doesn't,
he doesn't exercise well then he's nice,
right?
But when you talk and
consider physical health,
physical health is dependent upon choices.
It's dependent upon dietary choices and
it's dependent upon choices that you
make as far as like how much exercise
you do and that's your health.
I think mental health is the same thing.
I think there's aspects of mental
health that are undeniable,
just like these aspects of physical
health that are undeniable.
There's people that are born with
horrible physical diseases and, and, and,
and there's not much they can do
it physically to overcome those.
And there's all sorts of deformities and
all sorts of real problems that people
have that are physical.
But then there's also people that are
just fucking overeating lazy fucks and
they develop heart disease. Well isn't
that a physical health issue? Well,
it most certainly is and
have that physical health
health issue manifests itself
through choices and decisions and your
actions and so then it becomes a mental
health issue as well.
So it's a physical health issue,
but it's also a mental health
issue because it's your
mental health that is out
of line that allows your physical
health that gets so fucked up,
but also sort of people's
experiences in life.
I don't know if I take to mental a mental
health issue where they have an issue
with their brain, you know what I'm
saying? Where it's chemically different.
Sometimes they might not have had the
same opportunities as other people and
just say, listen man, fuck this.
Like maybe they lost a family member.
Maybe they lost their job and they're
thinking, oh, I'm sick of this shit man.
Yeah, that's true. Some of that.
But I think that could be considered
a mental health issue. I think t's,
I think prom with people chalk it up.
Everything has mental health like these,
like these uh, shooters, these
calls or these random shooters.
It's always a mental
health thing. Yes, right.
Oh well it's a mental thing
and that's an easy get away.
They might just be fucked up
man. Bad people. Some things up.
If people are just evil, man, we could,
but that also is I think
could be considered a mental
health issue and I think
the word mental health,
we get thrown around like we look at
health and disease and issues like that or
where you're not, you're not balanced
in an order. We look at it like, oh,
Jimmy caught gonorrhea. Well that guy's
got a disease he needs to penicillin.
But if you're just a lazy fuck that
eats like Shit and eventually your heart
gives out.
You have heart disease and
that is a physical disorder.
It's a physical disorder that came from
you not having discipline for whatever
reason, making poor choices so it
manifests itself in a physical condition.
It can also manifest itself in a,
in a a mental condition because you could
be at a point where we'd given up on
that feed.
Is that what's going on?
I got a lot of messages just saying that
that was the prelims and the act main
card is going on now alive.
Oh, nice. On the West.
So it was just the prelims line website
and that was what it was playing.
So the main car supposedly is live now.
Oh,
so what we were when they were
saying that we were watching,
we were watching the prelims. Yes.
Okay. That makes sense. So, um, okay,
now that we have that, let's put
up the card on the, okay, cool. Um,
but I think the word disease is an issue
and the word health is an issue because
it's, it's really like we categorize
things like health and disease and we,
we, we like, we'd get real
rigid with how we, uh,
look at them and we look at things
like health and these people that have
disorders. When you have addictions,
when you have compulsion's,
when you have a negative behavior that
you can't help but keep continuing to
repeat over and over again,
self sabotaging behavior,
that is a mental health issue.
When you have obsessive,
like you're a stalker, you start stalking
a girl, you won't leave her alone.
You're obsessed with her.
Check her Facebook,
her like that's that
obsession is a disorder.
Like you could call it
a mental health issue.
You could call it as you could call it
behavioral malfunction. True. But it's,
you're not healthy mentally and it,
so it is a mental health issue.
Like if you go into a school and you
shoot people 100% you have a mental health
issue,
100% 100% the issue is you can't be
mentally healthy and want to go and shoot
random people just so
people know your name.
You can't want that if you want
that you are mentally unwell.
And so I think when we look at
things like, oh, it's not his fault,
he has a mental health disorder.
Oh that's just a cop out. Well, no,
he's responsible for whatever
that disorder his butt.
He most certainly has a disorder. Like
when someone's a rapist, the bill Cosby,
okay, he's got a mental health
issue. It doesn't exonerate him.
It doesn't say that he should be free.
And no one should,
no one should prosecute him.
And you know,
he should somehow or another be
treated instead of a locked up.
No, no, that's not what I'm saying.
But you have to have a mental health
issue in order to drug women and fuck them
when they were unconscious.
You have to have a total disconnect
for feeling about that woman's health,
her safety, her, her physical
solidarity or, or, or,
or physical, um, uh, her, her ability to,
to like own her own body and own
her own consciousness. Like to,
for you to want to bypass that with a
pill so you could stick your Dick in her
like you have to be mentally, he was
raised that way. It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter because you even,
you can be mentally raised to be
racist like we were talking before.
Or you can be raised in a mental pattern
where you're homophobic though all
those are absolutely a hundred percent
possible. But at the end of the day,
you're still mentally unwell.
Like you're mentally unwell
because of the way you were raised,
your mentally unwell in spite of the
way you were raised. It doesn't matter.
You're mentally unwell.
Like,
and I think if we look
at behavior like overall,
like what is conducive to a happy
experience for you and the people that you
encounter,
what is conducive to you being
fulfilled in your life and having great
friendships and great relationships.
What is conducive to that? Well,
if you move towards that and he tried to
eliminate all the errors that you keep
repeating and making and you recognize
those that's healthy, that's healthy.
Well this is the thing
though. So if, if I,
if I am a of mental health issues,
there's a lot of negative that
comes with it, right? So, so if I,
whatever have this weird,
uh, inclination to,
to molest boys or whatever for whatever
reason, there you will for whatever,
whatever it is. Or to rape
girls. Yeah. Right, right.
It's going to be tough to get help,
right?
Because you have this negative
connotation with that. Sure.
So that's why it keeps going on.
Well, that's certainly a part of it.
And also there's not, and I'm not
promoting any of this fucking bullshit,
but I'm just saying there's no
like safe house for them. Right?
Like they can't go be
like, hey man, listen,
I have this weird fantasy where I
fucking loved him. Less little kids,
people like Wyatt. You know what
I'm saying? Like there's no,
there's no outlet for
him. It's true. I mean,
to have a fantasy where you victimized
small children is like the most taboo and
forbidden fantasy ever. You can't even
pee jerk off to that. But if you hadn't,
can't even vote 10, you're super
fucked. Well, say if a guy, um,
say if you're married,
right? And uh, you know,
maybe your wife puts on a few pounds,
but you want to stay married and
you don't want to cheat on her.
And yet she doesn't want
to have sex anymore.
Maybe she's older and she
gets the menopause and you
just go into your garage or
wherever the fuck you keep your porn and
you whack going off every now and then
just went off to stay sane.
Yeah, everything else is great,
but when you're closing your eyes,
you're whacking off and
you're looking at porn,
you're looking at some dirty girl
that tattoo on her lower back,
she sucking Dick and you
just want to her sure.
See you get, you're allowed to indulge
those fantasies. If you're a man,
like if you're a guy was
no chance whatsoever of a
banging some super hot porn
star 10 yeah. You could still jerk
off watching her. Fuck you can.
So that's what you like.
Yeah.
You could still jerk off watching
someone just hold her hair and just mouth
fucker.
You can do that and no repercussions.
Like you can never have
sex with that girl ever,
but you could jerk off to her having
sex and have no repercussions.
That's your taste. Right? But if your
taste is like young boys, like twinks,
like 15 year old tanks, you, you
have nothing. Everything is illegal.
It doesn't even mean that you want to go
out and have sex with those young boys
like, or you plan on having sex with us
was like, you can't even jerk off to them.
So what leads me to question like what
happens if in the future they figure out
virtual reality,
like they get virtual reality to
a point where it's just you can't,
anything goes,
anything goes in virtual reality.
So you have these artificial
young boys that blow you.
Will that be illegal because
no one's getting hurt there.
These artificial boys are made a three
d polygons are connected together with
some visual
video effects engine. It's harder
because it satisfies the urge. Right?
And they're not doing to
actual humans. Yeah. Right.
But eight that urge though, you want
to cut it out of the society. Okay.
So what are you doing it with these
guys? All right. I'm with you.
Them in the bank. You might
have to them in the bum. They
met him. Bumps. See Ya. I,
I wish there was a way to just rewire
you. I mean, I wish, I mean in all,
I bet a lot of people who
have all those issues,
those real dark people who are unhappy,
you don't think they wish they could
be rewired. Sure. Man. Even gamblers,
you ever meet? I'll take some great
wine. Rambler. Few things. Yeah.
You know what's really
interesting, someone was
talking to me about this stuff,
fat guy that I know and his wife was
saying that it's Kinda crazy because first
of all, that guy, what's
his name, halls and,
and is the biggest 185 pounds a large
human because gigantic for one 85.
I liked, I liked Michael Page.
Michael, he's fun to watch.
His talents are almost wasted in that
division that he's competing against.
He needs to fight like a much
higher caliber of fighter.
He's collecting paychecks. What was I
just saying? We're just talking about, oh,
you have a fat friend.
Oh. And his wife was like,
here's the difference between
being addicted to anything else.
Like if you're addicted to cigarettes,
you stopped smoking cigarettes and then,
you know, he kicked the habit.
But if you're addicted to food,
you have to eat food. It's a legit
boy. It was a very legit point.
I thought about it. I want to,
Whoa, it's a super legit point.
Obviously I don't have food issues. I'm
known have, um, you know, um, a real, uh,
food addiction. But over the last
nine days, I quit eating sugar,
lost six pounds. Now as of
today, six fucking pounds.
And I'm not trying like, I'm just
eating normal. I'm doing the same.
Doing more cardio or anything? Nope.
Same amount. Everything's the same.
Everything's the same.
But you're getting your sugar from where?
From the bucket name all
the mango things. Yeah.
I thought you were c two o c two
delicious and sweet. But it's,
that's natural. That's just
the coconut from fruit or
whatever. Yeah. Fruits. Fine.
I've been eating bananas every
day and I eat oranges and apples.
I eat a lot of fruit, but uh,
like those mangoes. So it's Chili.
Mangoes are so God damn good.
Heaven ain't much. I came in,
I felt that bad enough that you know what?
Yo Lo, fuck this. When's the last area?
Lo? I don't know why that
came out of my mouth.
I don't know why that came out
of my mouth. I don't even talk.
Lights got added sugar.
That's the problem.
It's not just the sugar
from the dried mangoes.
Did they put sugar and then
the chili sauce together?
The chippy Chili Pepper together, mangoes
from heavens. When I say heaven dust,
oh you mean sugar,
I'm fucking addicted man.
So I go nine days in and I
decided I'm going on a month.
Then I'm gonna see what happens when I
make it to a month. You know what though?
You're a real discipline type of dude who
can do that. You know what I'm saying?
Like you, you stick something
in your fucking sticking to it.
One thing I know about you,
I definitely do,
but what I'm thinking is
why I'm doing this. I'm man,
I don't even have an issue and this
is like overwhelming my thoughts.
Like a lot of the day,
like where I see like a hot dog with a
nice white roll on a white bun to white
bread. I'm not eating that
shit. I'm not eating that.
So I see that hot dog with
fucking Sauerkraut on it. Ooh,
you ever go to home depot and they have
the hot dog cart in front of Home Depot.
All those things are so fucking
good mother fucker to get me.
I'm going to have for our hammer.
I'm trying not to hammer.
I'm not trying to buy a hot dog too.
I ended up walking out what
that hot dog and a Chiro.
They get that Cheryl and I'm like, fuck
it. I'll, you know what gets me with them.
God Damn Churros the Charles and the
funnel cakes and Mickey mouse ears on and
Shit feeling like, Shit, I'm done dude.
I'm not no, no sugar for this month.
So I'm gonna see what happens.
And at the end of the month I'm going
to see how I feel and what I look like.
This is the helped me,
but is I'm assuming that everyone
in your household this way,
because if they're not, you're
going to have troubles. Now,
I used to date a girl who, uh, I
was trying to eat real healthy,
but she literally had crazy genetic.
She would eat fast food every night.
So I'd be like eating fucking,
you know, Broccoli and chicken.
She's balls deep in a 12 piece chicken
nugget. You know what I'm saying?
It's tough, man. It is. But
when I get it in my head,
it doesn't matter. You could
eat pizza right in front of
it. A beast with it. Well,
I just, I have switches.
I have like, okay,
now you don't do this anymore and that's
it. And once I don't do that anymore,
I don't do that anymore because
then if I do do it, if I give in,
that'll permeate itself from
the rest of my life. That'll,
that'll leak itself into my other
comedy leak itself into my workouts.
It'll leak itself in everything
you do that with your social life.
If someone fucked you over and you're
like your dad to me off, as soon as,
as soon as they like,
you will run into people that will like
either sabotage you or do a bad business
deal with you or try to fuck you in some
way. And you know, you can't hate him.
I forgive him like as a person,
but I won't associate with them anymore.
No. Yeah, there's no, yeah, no, no, no.
You mean you'd have to like have
some insane apology with the,
a real explanation and then,
you know,
we'd probably have to work our way
back to a French or she'll slow,
but when someone fucks you over,
I can't,
you can't tolerate that because those
people become problems. And those people,
that's a pattern that like, like if
you, uh, if you have a friend and like,
especially like you hear about friends
going into business together and then
like they start a restaurant or something
and one guy fucks off with the cash
and they wind up fighting each other.
My stepdad and his, uh, his, um,
he had a business partner
and architectural firm and
they beat each other up one
day. Should it be each other? Like he
came home, he had a black eye and he was,
you know, in his forties and
I was a kid. I was like, what?
First of all, I was like,
I was fighting back down to zero skills.
It's like this,
like what did this
fight look like between,
cause I knew his basic guess Stepdad or
worse, but it's like he's a good guy.
He's in a bad person, but I knew
the guy fought with two. I'm like,
that's even more ridiculous that that
guy gave you a black eye because that has
to be there.
It was so bad.
Well it was a very complicated
situation where they had uh,
government contracts and then,
um,
the government lost money. Um,
like there was like a d uh,
there was a recession and during the
recession they cancel a lot of their
contracts.
And so these guys had put all this time
and work and effort into these projects
and the projects were pulled out from
under them and all their investment was
done super fun. It was really
bad. And you know, they all,
I'm sure there was a lot of blame on
both sides and who knows what the fuck
happened. But it's weird when you see
someone come home, your Stepdad gets,
got a black eye.
What earth?
Like if I was braiding shop,
it'd be like, for sure.
Keep your hands up next time for sure.
Don't let them get that close to you.
Talk my shit to each other.
My Dad get in a fight when I
was 12 I'm not making this up.
W whatever fucking cars. Right.
My Dad pulls in front of him.
He pulls it from my dad. He gets out.
My Dad goes, you want to fucking go?
My Dad's like, oh no, like an
old school Irish boxer. Oh No.
I remember being like 10 or
11 being like, ah, fuck man.
See the problem with that is Nick
Diaz can actually fight like that.
Oh my dad makes off this dude.
Yeah.
It was about to throw them off the side
of the highway and a leather jacket.
Oh No, I did not fuck around
when a guy stands out like that.
So I was doing the old school boxing.
One of two things can happen.
He's trying to scare you off
or he's so good with his hands.
He's just Kinda roll actually. Like what's
up dude? You want some? Yeah, man. Yeah,
he was weird. I'll tell
you what, for real man,
I remember my dad get out of
the car. I'm like, God dammit.
And then my brother gets out, kicks,
guiding the balls from behind.
[inaudible] was probably 12 at the time.
He's Christ brother kicked a grown
man in the room in the balls.
But that's when it gets really
dangerous when that kid gets involved,
own father becomes like super violent.
Little Brown was doing what was
a little crying in the back seat.
How old were you? Probably like
10 or 11 crying in the back seat.
Can't be trusted if she goes down.
Our nurse on my stepdad fight but it's,
I'm almost getting a fight once
we got in a minor car accident,
like a little fender bender when I was
like eight or nine years old and I was as
young kids and saw the car and they got
out swearing and yelling and I was like,
oh no, I was so scared.
So skin, oh so scared.
Cause he wasn't a tough guy either.
I was told me cry. So vulnerable,
prominent on might have.
I don't think so cause I don't think
it got to the point where anybody hit
anybody. So I probably see,
I would definitely have
cried if they hit each other.
Yeah, I would've been terrified.
But that's how people die. You know,
that's how people wind up killing
the whole family was real man,
knocked the guy out. The Guy
Falls, hits his head, you go,
we got to get rid of the family
and they just, they mark Burg wife,
free butter kids. That shit happens. You
know, you run into the wrong biker gang.
True. They're messed up and trying
to prove their hardness for sure.
Shit happens.
Carbon w you know you're the wrong race.
You know you're a black guy and there's a,
you know,
you have a white girlfriend maybe. Who
the fuck knows man? Yeah man. Anything.
You know.
How about transgender people?
How about a transgender person gets in
the car accident with a bunch of fucking
amped up dudes? Oh the fuck. Yeah. I mean,
and you're on a dirt road somewhere
in the middle of nowhere and you just
decided to beat this guy. The
dude, I need a gun for real man.
If you need any fucking, most
people really need a gun. Oh yeah.
That should alarm everybody because I can
fight. Yeah. People need it done right.
It's a weird thing out there.
You could run it to the wrong people.
And I've had people say that to me
like you're so paranoid, you know,
like why do you want
to learn martial arts?
Like I had this conversation with
Mark Marin wants about this, you know,
it's like well is that really
gonna Happen? Like you're
really worried about it.
Like I've seen it like I know bad people.
I've seen people do bad things to be
blessing people hit people and they didn't
have to, I just can't be set the
same thing. Cause I asked him,
I'm like why should I have a gun?
He's like,
cause if shit goes down you want
to be prepared man. He goes,
I never go anywhere without a gun.
He goes,
cause my wife and my
kids are depending on me.
It was the 11th that guy has a gun and
yeah I have all these findings because
what the fuck am I going to do? He was,
I would never let them down. And he's,
you know, world class fighter worldclass
and he's saying this, I was like, damn,
I need a gun. But he's always trying
to find one off the black market.
Why would you from when you can
get one for Rome? And he was like,
get the fuck out it. Yeah. Don't even say
it was a joke. It was a Joe. Yeah. Lie.
We lie. We just lied you 100%.
You can get one. You know,
legally. You gotta feel easier
today. Yeah. It's not hard.
It's not hard. Wink, wink, wink. It's
not hard to get a gun in California.
Paperwork and shit and not hard.
Do I have to take lessons? No,
that's what's crazy. Whose phone is
that? Is that mine or yours? I wouldn't,
definitely not mine. Um, you,
you don't have to like fill out
paperwork. At least he didn't. When I did,
I mean for paperwork as
far as like take a test,
just kind of give me the goddamn thing.
It's not a hard like a hunter safety.
Like when you take a, you take a
hunter safety course, um, you could,
you do most of that online and
then you go and take like a class.
Is there a weight class you,
I don't want to do that.
I'm going to go black market.
Is there a, is there a,
is there a waiting period for
what? For a guy full. Yes. Yes sir.
I don't want to, I don't hand handgun
for any kind of firearm. There's a gun.
There's a waiting period. They
have to find off. You're crazy.
They have to find out if you're a felon,
it's running from the law.
They have to find out if you're
really Brendan shop, Bro,
give me a goddamn gun on me, bro.
Goddamn gun. You can get a gun, man.
It wouldn't be any problem. But Joey Diaz
can't get a gun. Joey Diaz is a felon.
That makes sense. Yeah. If you're a felon,
you can't get a gun that, I mean that's,
yeah, it's tricky man. Joey Diaz. But,
but makes sense if you just look
at his record on paper. Yeah.
It's tough to sell that
guy gun. Well, it's just,
it seems like a questionable moe. Legit.
I mean, there's a reason for the law.
You will, you watch his podcast even watch
that. The morning thing that he does.
We see a hoax that's high. The
morning joint. Yeah, it's he stays.
He's doing peer skill. Yes. I stopped
fucking pair of scout man. Yeah.
Yeah, I'm gay. People get super excited
about it, but the excitement waned.
It went away and I was like, yeah,
you know, I don't like it either.
And then Facebook's doing video streaming,
you know? Really? Yeah. They're all,
that's video streaming. That's right.
For out for however long you want. Dude,
we should start streaming on Facebook.
That's what people are streaming and
cut out the middleman. Youtube. Well,
youtube is not bad to youtube. We make
money off youtube. Make money off ads.
They play ads. No, for
sure. Podcast. Yeah,
you can make money off of videos.
I make money off my haters videos.
People make mean videos about me.
I put ads on them. Type Move Tropo.
Yeah, type move, man. Shit.
That's fun money. Keep on
keeping on. Ultimately. I mean,
do you get that much hate though?
Shore. Really sure. I don't see it. Oh,
you got to look around. I don't see why
I don't look at the four people. Well,
if people hate every
show that is on the air,
there's going to be a certain percent.
It was like we were talking about,
you have a guy like, like that
was talking about that Milo, God,
but even you or even Callen
or anyone who I love,
there's going to be a certain percentage
of people that fucking hate them.
Can't stand that.
It's just everybody's not for everybody.
That dude went down from
those fucking leg kicks, man.
Some big boys tattooed on the left
is throwing some nasty leg kicks,
a white guys getting ate up.
He's down from those legs.
Really big boys. When you see
like good high level kickboxing,
it makes you realize like a lot of the
kickboxing that you see in MMA especially
like like doesn't this level.
It just doesn't compare like this.
The one you're watching here,
these guys are going well to myself.
Oh boy wants out. Yeah, he does.
He's one of my left leg kick.
Yeah, for sure. Don't bend over like,
yeah. When he kicked that left leg,
you can see that the thunder bolt, the
pain go up into his dome. Um, yeah.
People hate everything,
man.
There's somebody out there to
hates fucking led Zeppelin.
Somebody out there that hates Bob Seger.
There's something out there that it wants
Billy Joel to jump into the river and
drowns in his own feces as,
as long as it's 60 40 you're good.
But if everyone hates you, you might just
be fuck. Why do you think 60 40 is good?
I think what's probably good is
like 80 20 or 70 30 but yeah,
it should be on the higher end for sure.
Oh, it's just a day. 60 40 is like, hmm,
maybe you need to tighten up your
fucking game. Tighten it up. You suck.
And it's also like,
there's like a problem with doing things
like a podcast because you're talking
and you might have an opinion that
there's not the same as the person who's
listened to and they can't talk
back and it's fucking frustrating.
I think you're talking some shit about
like maybe some music that they love or
some food that they love
or whatever the fuck it is,
and they're listening and they
get mad. Like, I'm fucking tired.
Listening is bullshit. You
know, you fucking idiot. You
don't know shit. You fuck.
And it's because it's an intimate
relationship, but it's very one way true.
But however,
if you listen to a
hundred Joe Rogan podcast,
the Joe Rogan expansion isn't 101 of
them piss you off and then you become a
hater off that one.
Well,
that's not lose my fucking number
necessarily have to be the case.
They can be a hater from the jump, you
know? Oh, well then there's just a hater.
Then they're looking for any reason.
It's just always punch.
I'll tell you why I made the smartest
thing I ever did was that podcast before.
I got so much hate. Fucking people
hated me or standing. I get it.
I mean, I dressed like Jay Leno and
I get a fucking part in my head.
You know what I'm saying? Like
I get it. Part looks good. Yeah.
It depends who you ask. I like it. It's
like a giant Tobey Maguire. Just depends.
People that hate, you know they don't,
they don't matter. Yeah, I agree.
They don't matter.
I'm just saying the best thing I ever
did was the podcasts because people are
like, oh, he's not that
big of a dick. Yeah.
Well they didn't understand a lot of like
when you would say things like this is
just your personality,
your sense of humor.
Like they think this guy really
thinks he's the shit. Well yes and no.
Like in a way. Yeah, but in another way.
No. Like he's having fun. This is fun.
Yeah. What is this? Kevin Hart and
the soccer player? David Beckhams,
this soccer player, soccer player that
they always try to sneak in on us,
not buying it. I get
it. I get it. He's cute.
Whatever. Well, whatever he is, get
outta here. It's not working. Oh,
hello. I live in America land.
The free home of the brave.
We don't give a fuck who the world ping
pong champion is. Okay. But soccer bro,
same thing. He's the captain of
England for a long time. Darts.
Who gives a fuck sick.
His fate was sealed when he came
home to La to play with the Mexicans.
It's fate was sealed. They didn't
even give a fuck about them. A few,
like really a few really horny girls in
their thirties came down because they
were like super attracted him to work.
David back didn't work as work. So No,
I'm saying it didn't work as far as like
getting us to buying the soccer did not
work.
Did Not paid them like one,
two gillion dollars didn't work
and like seven people showed up.
No one give a feel like this is still
soccer. David Beckham is hot ticket.
What we need is a recognizable face. We
got them too late. We got in too late.
It didn't matter if he's fucking man,
Diego Maradona in his and he's got a dick.
It's made out of gold.
It doesn't matter. It's
still soccer, soccer stuff.
If that guy was playing baseball,
Holy Shit Dude. Make a rod.
You know? I mean the, the, the damage
that guy's like a rod do. I mean he would,
he would make that look silly. I
agree. He would be way better. He's,
he's a beautiful man. Oh, a piece tattooed
up too. But he doesn't have the build.
It doesn't have to build because in
soccer it's like not important to have
muscles. You look, I
feel like some bitches be
the ones you don't want to fuck Trump
tie. Right? Oh, you're 100% yeah.
What do you want those? Nah. Well those
girls who want a guy that's tight,
he's tired all the time. A guy like
a weak frame kind of gets neck pains.
That's not what they want. No, that's not
what they want. They want a big brown. The
super athlete. Dick, was that a, the
stoppage of that fight? Well, some girls,
like some girls, like real skinny
dudes. Oh, in all seriousness,
some girls like dudes there look like
they're like don't eat. I think the,
I saw a study where the,
where the the most appealing for women.
It was like kind of that dad bod, like
not a real rip dude, but not a fat dude.
Some fat dude was trying to
get some pussy. It's bullshit.
They're trying to and you hate whoever
wrote that gives you a rare deal and they
trying to get into the heads where they
say all the women out there and like,
like hypnotize them.
It's true.
Well they already did it with the
fucking skinny bitches. Those,
the models leave their coat racks.
Girls Look at those models and think
that's what they need to look like.
Other girls, not for guys. Right?
But they think that's what
they're supposed to look like.
If they just want it to look good
for guys, they would listen to us.
It's called honey doing squats and
they would be eating pasta or rice
slideshows. Nice sour cream,
boom. Sauerkraut and pork chops,
pork chop on the basic bitch
carb and carb up stairs, ruts.
You got to work those
glutamates and I says,
but to like women who like
look at those like really tall,
thin women, they think that that's,
that's what they have to achieve.
Who's off fuck the fuck it's from
television man. It's from movies.
It's from books.
It's from magazines rather.
It's so what do the guys
get the guys get we, we get,
we look towards what the Rock and
shit and muscle fitness. Yeah there's,
there's that and then there's like a
ridiculously people like guys who are just
like super shredded six pack guys
are sitting around like almost like,
you know that guy when he took that
photo shoot didn't eat for at least a day
dehydrated himself to show his ass.
He was on an eight week
funding cut to get the,
when you see ads and guys look insanely
ripped and they have like chiseled six
packs either they're a freak of nature,
which is occasionally have those,
a guy just looks insane no matter what
he does like the Kevin Randleman look,
you know, or oh you mean black people?
That's what I was going, sorry.
Or sorry.
You,
you got a guy who is preparing for a
photo shoot who's in a very unhealthy and
dehydrated state. You know when you see
those guys for people that don't know,
if you watch bodybuilding and you see
those guys in there on that podium at that
stage and their flex in and
you see the strike [inaudible],
they will black out.
If you made those guys run up a hill,
they would literally black out and
fall down. They have a zero endurance.
They would die.
If that competition lasted four days
dead, they'd be dead. They'd be dead.
If it was like an endurance thing where
you had to keep the competition going
over days and days, they would
be gone. It'd be gone. Yeah.
They don't look like that. Yeah, there's,
it's not healthy. You can't do that.
So if men had a body dysmorphia thing,
it would be about being ripped.
Like that's why when that girl was fucking
with you 100% saying you were soft,
feel like, Ooh. She's like,
she's saying you don't look like this
unrealistic person from these magazines
that I'm fingering myself too. And I said,
bitch, you don't look like Nicki Minaj.
Where are we going to do? What are we
going to do? She wasn't even back then,
that she wasn't popular. I didn't
really work. I probably said,
did you guys have an argument over it?
No, I, I was just like, you were hurt. Uh,
yeah. And I was like, I'm sad, sad.
I state this girl used to tell me about
her ex boyfriend who she dated this big
giant body builder dude,
that he used to pick her up and fuck
her up against the wall. And I'm like,
do you really think I want to hear that?
You don't want to know that.
So why do you want to tell
me about some big Guy?
He used to pick you up and fuck you
against the wall because I can pick you up
and fuck you against the wall. You're not
that big. Yeah. If you want to do that,
she'll, yeah, I'm strong
enough to do that.
But I don't need to know
about other than you.
I like to pretend that
specific way that you can,
like I'm the first one and I don't
fucking picture any of that man.
I still a bit about that,
that every girl should say,
is that what a Dick looks like? I'm
so glad I waited. That would be great.
That would be fucking brilliant.
Speaking is how I've always thought it
would be the best way to suck it and then
just do an ace five star Bordeaux style
wifey and you're like, wait a minute.
How'd you learn? Ho I don't want to know.
I don't want it.
I don't want to know.
I'll just pretend you fucking
learned it off videos. Speaking of,
speaking of Dicks, did you speaking
to take Justin Bieber's Dick?
Cause I get to bring up, I knew it. I
knew you were going to bring up a dude.
It's got a good Dick.
Good sized hoggy items.
Kids happy kids gets killing the game,
Bro.
Think that maybe he like
pulled it out a little,
fluffed it out a little blood flow,
knew everybody was going to see it.
You know he had that die piece
of a girl waiting on the couch,
so I'm sure he phoned her. He's Justin
Bieber and then was like, you know what?
I'm going to get butt naked,
play some guitar on the balcony
and someone caught them like,
I don't think he's walking around with
that big old hug like that. That's true,
but also making it though.
Maybe it doesn't give a fuck.
Maybe when you have $300 million
and you're 19 you're like,
maybe I'll just go show my hog and
everybody for real dog out for a walk.
Especially
take feral hog out on the balcony,
this hog up for a little stroll and he's
got to think like as famous as he is at
everything he does, he's constantly got
people. Try to take pictures of him.
You'll have, if you have that hoggy
though, it's like fuck it. Why not? Yeah,
let it, let it breathe, Bro. Let
it shine. Quit hating on the Dick.
That's a good point. Yeah.
Right pony. Legit point. Good
for him. See that something.
Forget about squats. Forget about titty
implants, lips, then out a God damn thing.
You can do nothing.
Not incredible that if you look at the
game when the genetic game, all right,
that one of the number one things is
dick size number one things. Number one,
one of the number one things and that is
the one fucking nut that science can't
crack.
We could put a man on the moon.
We can send video from your fucking
cell phone to a dude in Australia.
Instantaneously we could,
you can download Netflix
on the ride to the airport.
I mean, you're pulling movies
out of the sky. Hindu some shit.
God Damn,
you can do some shit.
You could Skype with people there
on the other side of the planet.
Talk to them in real time.
Look at them like I'm looking at you.
That's all possible. Can't fix that
Dick. Can't fix this arc, bro. Sorry.
Uh, how, how, how close are
you getting close, close, man.
Nine o'clock and I'm just shit out.
Nothing.
We could cut the tendon in the bottom
and stretch it out, but I mean,
what can you do? Me a
half an inch. My Buddy,
I won't say his name
obviously has a small Dick.
I was at his house the other day awhile
ago, found a Dick extender for his girl.
He saw, he saw me, he saw
me see this fucking adapter.
I sleep Damson I get it bro.
You coulda.
I coulda roasted them hard,
hard for having a tiny Dick
and having a Dick extender.
Now when you say Dick extended like a
rubber Dick that you put on top of your
house to help your girl out cause
she here's a Tater tot dick.
So he put this thing on top of it.
It's a bomber,
bro. Me Being the nice guy just
looked at him, said, I get it.
It's just carry on with your night.
It is what it is, man. Number man.
You can't do shit like if, if you're
real skinny, all right, whatever.
You can lift weights,
eat right.
Maybe even by some steroids we can figure
some shit out. Like you said, your Dick.
We've got three d printing where we're
making all sorts of fucking new Oregon's
whatever the fuck you went. We
can't do dick. I got a question.
When you see like women that are
bodybuilders and they take steroids, they,
their clit grows and then
it becomes like a dick.
Do you think of a dude got on
some crazy ass fucking steroids?
Would it make his dick grow?
I'll give you got on some wild silver
back Mark Coleman in 1996 type steroids.
You know,
so some top of the fucking food chain,
Alexander Karelin type shit.
Cause
when you did grow up, you're like,
it would, I think it would grow.
Your balls are going to shrivel up.
You raise it,
but you take is going to be balls.
Your ball's going to have to step away
from the game. They're not doing the job.
You know,
it's like what if you have a four cylinder
engine and your race car and someone
comes along and say, listen,
we've got one or two choices.
We can either take out this bitch ass
four cylinder and put in this ls seven six
point whatever leader, motherfucker,
you fire breathing dragon per engine.
Or you can keep up with your bullshit
fuel economy in that Shitty Putt Putt.
What are we going to do? We're here to
win races. While you take that crazy,
you know, Mark Carr, Haga engine 2001,
you know mark the smashing
machines at his peak.
They take some of that stuff.
You know what?
I don't know if your Dick grows longer.
I think it might get fat
or might get bigger too.
I mean just the girls click gets bigger.
How does this Dustin Jacoby next,
is that next? Oh, that's a good
fun. That's comin event. Beautiful.
Beautiful product. Yeah. He's a tough
kid, man. UFC too, right? Yes he did.
Tough kid. Um, I wonder,
I w I think genetic engineering
is going to be where it's all at.
That's what's going to,
we'll get there and pretty soon the rosy,
we walk around with Dicks to try
to asses big Dicks, giant deck,
seek noses. I just have this bit about
big Dick Pills that have big dick pills.
Really worked.
It would take about 30 minutes for
the first guy to die of an overdose.
And then I go, cause no
one's going to take one. Oh,
big Dick pills work it. Take one makes my
Dick groat. What if I take all of them,
puts out like how much do I take before
I die? And I'll take one less than that.
Yeah. This fucking party
rolling. When I was like that,
there's a Jacoby fighting that guy that
we just saw that one earlier right there.
Jacoby is one of the guys are beating him.
The guy that we saw earlier that a knocked
out Bang Bang on buyers are going to
be done. Yeah. And Wayne
parents, bad mother fucker.
He's very good. Super Athletic.
Real quick. Real sneaky man.
Really, really good athlete.
Good boxer too. He's a good boxer.
Before he, uh, got into kickboxing.
He's a real good athlete too.
There's a lot of real good guys at high
level in this. So I mean you're, you're,
you know, a shilling. I wonder
how it works with glory.
Like are they contracted to Gloria
or they can't find anywhere else is,
but is it the, you know, the
bell, Tor and Gloria are friendly,
but can he fight elsewhere?
Can he fight over in Japan or,
I don't know how it was contrary to
how those contracts are. I don't know.
They have glass. Be Tough. Paul
Daley too though that Paul Daley,
he's in both belter and like I said,
that makes sense for those guys.
It's just whatever it is.
For whatever reason,
Bella [inaudible] has been
around for a long time now. Okay.
It's been around for several years
and for whatever fucking reason,
it just has not caught on the way the
UFC caught on in like the early 2000.
Never. Well, that doesn't
make sense to me. They don't,
they don't have the stars don't have the
depth. They don't have the production,
but they have don't have the money. Right.
They have Viacom money. Crazy money.
Why doesn't Viacom's say,
look,
we can either have this middling product
where we're always going to have like a
good guys like Phil Davis and
Tito Ortiz and you know, uh,
Sheila Manco and good fighters.
Or we can go balls out and we can
get the really good guys like cool.
Like anybody,
anybody that's in contract negotiations.
Chad Mendez was talking to them
when Chad Mendez had, you know,
his contract is about to come up.
You don't think that he got offers?
I don't know what his deal was and I
don't think he was even thinking about
going, but you don't think
that rampage went over there?
You know rampages in it will lawsuit
right now where he's got to figure out
where he's going to fight again if
he is ever going to fight again.
The UFC said they would let them go.
They said, yeah. They said, look,
we understand that you're in this
big lawsuit with Viacom and Viacom's
threatened to sue the UFC, said,
we'll let you go. You could.
You could go and fight for them and yeah,
it was cool for them to do that.
I think they're offering to settle
[inaudible] Viacom's offering to settle.
They want,
because they did violate his contract.
It did 100% he did fight
Fabio Maldonado afterwards.
The judge cleared him to fight.
So I don't know what the
specifics of the case was,
but is the last that I read
was that you're looking at,
you're looking at a 10 year investment
where we're going to have to get these
young guys from from the UFT and then
we're going to have to recruit the younger
guys who come up cause guys come
up through the ranks, right?
Like Phil Davis or the ultimate fighter
came up for the ultimate fighter.
A bunch of guys.
Did they have to figure out kind of
their feeder system because right now all
they're doing is biting off the
UFC. Really? Let's be really, yeah,
they're putting on B level c level
shows that the UFC put it on. T five,
six years ago,
Phil Dave's kind of the first guy who's
in his prime who went there, you know.
But Phil, Dave's isn't a knockout artist.
I love Phil. Phil Davis just knocked out,
uh, what's his face? Um, um, uh, hold,
hold the Karma Karma come home.
[inaudible] very good fighter.
And Davis beat the shit out. I
knocked him out. He looked nasty.
No Davis fuck those dudes up. It's
like a, he turned a corner, you know,
and like did he turn to corner? Is
He fighting lesser competition? Both.
I think both the,
I agree.
I think Davis is getting better and I
think Dave says in his prime and he's,
he's going to run that show for a very,
very long time.
I was super impressed when he beat Glover.
I was like, wow, that is a big victory.
But I think Glover had a shit camp.
I really did feel big victory though.
Whatever, whatever miscues Glover makes.
That's a huge Vic hundred percent. But um,
I was disappointed when he lost a baiter.
But then when you see the way Bader beat
Rashad, you're like, look, Bader need,
you need to consider Bader
the way he is right now.
Don't consider how Bader got knocked out
by Glover or bater that got knocked up.
I'm a cheetah five in a row. He's won
five in a row and look fucking real good.
But guess what's next for
him though? You're a mother
fucker and Anthony Johnson.
Yeah. Couldn't be worst matchup. Is that
happening? Because I'm bill asked for.
I think that's what's next for him
cause what are you going to do?
You're going to sit out and
wait for John and DC to fight.
Who knows how long that's going to be.
They're going to make you fight rumble,
terrifying,
rumbles,
terrifying and I can't think
of worst matchup for Beta
and I love Beta, but if I,
if it, if I'm being, I'm like God, if I'm
Beta, I'd rather fight Jon Jones then rub.
I can't think of a worst matchup for him.
There's some interesting fights
at two oh five real interesting.
Real interesting. I was really surprised
how well he shot were shot down.
I was really surprised. I was like,
wow, Bader has really turned a corner.
He's really a fight to say that.
Well it's just because your shot had
two years layoff, but Beta look real
good. I'm only basing it on how good
bait or looked. He looked real good.
He looked real smoothly to stand up.
He's getting way better.
His Jab is nasty man.
The was really getting up a lot of the
other aspects of a striking because he's
developed a rhythm with his jab where his
jab become so fluid and efficient that
he can like kind of half out there.
He can half it and then pop you with it.
He's landing it in like a more
diverse way than he ever did before.
He has more proficiency, like his
proficiency with his jam. I agree.
He looks great. Wayne Co main event.
Wayne Barrett versus Dustin Jacoby.
Um, he paid her. Does look
great. I think it's tough to,
it's tough. The base it off the Rashad
fight. I agree with you. I agree with you.
That was a real tough fight for Rashad.
I think Rashad rubbed on it better to
have a fight with someone who wasn't a
member. Yeah. But think about Bateman.
It think what Betas come from marijuana.
He lost a fucking Tito Ortiz and
it's two in a row. Very lost.
A Tito Ortiz Maritio teasers
like hit him and he's like,
he hit him and then he chokes
them. Edit them. Yeah. Yeah.
But that motherfucker man,
because Ortiz,
if he's on and he catches you,
he's still Tito Ortiz, Tito Ortiz.
Gotta remember he was
at one point in time,
the motherfucker that is
put down in there until,
I mean not really because
chuck was always out there.
We always knew that chuck was out there,
but for before he fought chuck,
when you think of what he did,
Evan Tanner and you think of like the
beat downs he put on Kevin and Ken
shamrock. Yeah man. Like
he's still cute. The wage.
He was like one of the first guys
never use a one arm guillotine.
He a choked out. Yuki Kondo in Japan.
Remember that? Well, think about, um,
such a pan. I think it was, well,
think about bait or though that he was
too lots of the road and just lost to
Tito Ortiz. He was like on the chopping
block, man. I remember just being like,
damn, really Beta. Well
that dude, just boom.
Dustin Jacoby is going after Wayne
Barrett is a dangerous fight for Jacoby
because Barrett has fought
more elite competition.
Like he's fought Joe Schilling
beat Joe Schilling once.
Lost Joe Schilling in the last fight.
Not Joe Schilling down like he's,
he's dangerous.
And Jacoby is a,
I forget the Brazilian cat that
he got knocked out by dude.
I say mcnichols arena. That arena has
been shut down for literally 15 years.
That's Magnus Urena.
Magnus mcnichols is old school where
you'll see like two and three happened to,
this is a good fight. Wayne
Barrett. He slick man.
Look at that. Oops. Not here. Oh yeah.
Jacoby's like super aggressive too.
I forget that dude that he fought this
bad ass Brazilian cat put was Dustin
Jacoby's record bad ass dude
who caught him with a left hook.
Do it's tough cause Jacoby came to
the UFC and just struggled. Right?
Because you can't fight like
this well off, have to get
off like this. It's, it's,
it's a different style. Fighting with
the small gloves, that's for sure.
How did he lose to,
that's MMA. MMA The wall.
That's all MMA. See you fine. Um,
destined. Jacoby's a kickboxing career.
Um,
we could duck under coe.
He slicky duck under the looping
right hand. Yeah. It's just,
um, the, the, the big gloves thing. The
defense is so much different. Oh, 100%.
And that's what happened.
A shilling and shilling his last fight,
he got caught with that superman
punch by that dude. That was bad.
Who was ruthless shit happens. But
those punches, they come down on angles.
There is
Dan.
That stretch from 13 to 15 was tough.
Why can't I read that script?
Make that Casey Green
Burials Perera Alex Berrera.
Yeah, it was pretty last diaper. Yeah,
that's who it was. It was Pereira. Um,
demis fought all over. Yeah, you got a d.
It's a totally different style of
defense when you using the small gloves,
the big loves give you so much more
leeway to catching punches and the punches
themselves are bigger. That gloves are
bigger so the punches are coming at you.
It's a larger object coming at you and
you have a larger object to catch that
larger object and all that shit is shrunk
and considerably when you put those
MMA gloves to the Max Day,
it'd be like these guys fighting
with their hand wraps on.
It's completely different game. What do
you think about the idea of no gloves?
I won't work. No. Oh, I'm, if you
hate money and ratings, it'll work.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, like it's rough.
It's rough enough now being mainstream,
you know,
I don't think we're still mainstream.
I think we're still working
on that with the top sports.
You take gloves off and these dudes are
bare knuckle fucking dudes up. Yeah,
it makes sense to us. Right. It
makes sense that the educated people,
but I mean made America sees that shit.
General People like what the
hell? This is so barbaric. Right.
That's the only thing. Yeah,
maybe. I don't know man. I mean,
why is it barbaric to punch in the face
and not barbaric to knee in the face.
I'll come show I'm with you 100% take
the gloves off. It's safer. It is. It is.
I'm with you. However, marketing
wise, good luck selling
that. They're like, hold up.
We're going back to the Kimbo slice
backyard brawl days thought we were moving
forward. Well you would have a lot
of dudes breaking their hands too.
That'd be a real problem.
It'd be a real problem for like longevity
of your career and people think I'm
exaggerating. Listen, take away the
hand wraps. Take away the wrist wraps.
No risk wraps.
Cause I think one of the flaws of the
human hand and wait for punching is the
wrist.
It's hard.
Like you have to have Rick real
discipline to punch hard and you have to
practice hitting things bare knuckle
to really develop that rigidity in your
wrist when you deliver the,
the impact of a punch.
Because most people when they hit things,
their wristbands back twist sideways.
Most people don't know.
They wind up breaking their hands.
They hit with the
knuckles and the outside.
Well that's why boss would open hand
slap pitches. Well the is doing that now.
He was, he was fighting Pancrase so
it's the only way you could fight.
He figured out that was the
rules of Pancrase. Yeah.
Also did it though when they had gloves,
he used open hand.
Shit ruined when they had
gloves. He did that. Yeah. He,
he would throw throws hooks with an open
hand. He said. Interesting. Yeah. Huh.
Well, that's one of the reasons
why probably transferred
so easily to pancreas.
Damn. It was a good fight. You know,
one of the things that boss figured
out how to do in some weird way,
he figured out how to pull his hand back
way far. So when he was hitting guys,
he was hitting him like a punch with the
palm. Yeah, with the base of the palm,
like right where it reaches a
like where the, the palm is, um,
meets the wrist joint. He would pose
hands so far back, like unnaturally far,
if you watch his fights,
it's kind of weird how far his hand was
like the first freak athlete to get the,
I mean, he was a freak athlete man
who's the first elite striker in MMA,
in my opinion,
him and most Smith.
But he was probably the
first cars with moe.
He really didn't know any grappling to
speak of when we first started fighting
and Pancrase he,
you know,
he really had to learn more grappling
before we could see like an extreme
fighting.
You've got to see what his kickbox.
It was really like when you
act out Culann Soviet era,
that's when everybody was like, Oh
shit, like this is some next level shit.
And then when he came over to the UFC
and beat Mark Coleman and won the title,
people are like, oh, okay, this
is what a kickbox are really low.
It's like a world class. Kickboxer
boss said he taught himself Jujitsu.
That's madness. Crazy. Right?
Then you'd watch videos and teach
himself had a training partner,
just humans trading partner with
learning. Hey, I tried this on you.
How crazy is that? I believe
it. Awesome bosses. Crazy bitch.
Savage hit some crazy ideas
about conditioning too. He goes,
when are we kicked the bag? I would go
100% and how long can I do? 30 30 seconds.
100% well tomorrow I'll do 40 seconds
and then I do two minutes and then Tracy
do to build it up so that he could
get to like whatever the round was.
It was just sprint God
the different time back then.
Well they didn't, you
know. Now people do Tabata.
When you do a elliptical and you do
like a intervals like Tabata intervals,
we do what is the,
is like 20 seconds,
10 seconds off the typical Tabata.
What I do when I do a sprint,
like if I'm in a hotel and I have a
nothing but elliptical machine at the gym,
I'll do sprints on the elliptical machine
while crank it up. So like whatever,
really high level and I'll do 30
minutes of thunder, I call it,
or 30 seconds of thunder. I was like 30
minutes now god Damn, 30 seconds. Well,
30 minutes for the whole workout,
but for the thunder it's 30 seconds on,
30 seconds off.
That's,
it gives me something to do and
like those 30 seconds off like, oh,
I know it's common. I know it's common.
Here comes up fucking 20 minutes.
I think it's a part of the way to do
it because you're not so focused on the
overall time.
Me and my folks on 30 30 30 30 30 it
also gets you used to being completely
exerted. It's a great way to, to
get a cardio workout. Um, piece.
I'm like, what people think
of like a hardcore workouts.
You think of an air dine or maybe a,
a versa climber.
Like those you think of is
like Hark averse climber.
You can get the same kind of insane
workout on an elliptical machine,
hundred percent, but people associate
elliptical with like, you know,
you're watching the news going slow.
When I use the elliptical machine,
people look at me like something
fucking wrong with you.
I go hard in the paint on and I go
fucking hard on the elliptical. Now,
hard in the paint, in the paint. What does
that mean? Just like this mask authors.
I like
the pill hard in the motherfucking
paint us round two or three rounds.
Three damn. Dustin Jacoby. Uh, you don't,
you don't how we're starting to see a
trend where guys are sparring less and
less because they realize the
abuse and the gym that, uh,
Rodriguez was saying how he only sparked
three times I think in camp. Yeah. Yeah.
Year. Um, I think Brian, Stan
was saying that. Yeah. Well.
We'll just see Jacoby trying to,
we'll get Dustin Jacoby really
taking it to a man. He looks great.
He looks really improved
too from the Pereira fight.
I think a that knockout really,
uh, taught him a lot about defense.
He's looking great in this fight,
man. Good leg kick right there.
Barrett's thrown with the but look how
like how easy it is to block punches with
these God damned gloves. It's such
a different game. It's so different.
Look at this John Wayne par when he
does that cage. [inaudible] Todd,
did they wear MMA gloves or
do they wear gloves? Yeah,
he has a fight coming up Friday.
He's coming out here soon.
He's fighting black dynamite.
I liked them in um,
in cage Moitai and he's out here fighting
for the title San Diego in a, yeah,
in lion fight. He's going to fight
for the title. I liked that guy too.
He's a good dude. Yeah. Really good dude.
Funny. Yeah. I got to work out with him,
man.
He showed me some his and was that really
interesting way of throwing punches?
Like he throws everything hard. Like, even
his jab is hard. He makes it count. Jab.
He pulls back with his right
hand. Oh Shit. Wayne Barrett
went down. What happened?
Oh my God. So it's uh, he's,
he was touching the back of his head like
it was a bad strike and he's out of it.
Oh, he's super out of it. That's
it. Whoa. Dustin Jacoby knocked out.
Wayne Barrett and Wayne Barrett is a,
he was pointing to the back of his head.
He pointed to the back of his head earlier
in the fight too. Damn. Justin Jacoby.
Congratulations. Good for you.
Um, what was I just saying?
A fucking John Van. John Wayne par.
He throws punches like this.
He pulls back on his right hand.
This is how he throws a jab.
He goes like that. She said,
I've worked out with them for like an
hour and a half. We did awesome. Yeah,
it was really fun.
He's a good dude.
He's showed me a lot of cool
shit to a lot of cool shit.
Like the way he delivers is interesting
too. Damn. That is legit as fuck.
What does he point in the back of his
head for the, you could see that again,
that'd be one where you got hit.
He was getting battered
before he got dropped there.
I mean that was not just that one
shot either. What happened? Oh,
they went to a commercial, so I
wanted to see that knocked down again.
That's another thing. I
don't Miss Boxing. No.
Any box and I'll watch fucking
all of, we have a a thing, right?
Can we rewind that for a second? I just
want to see that knocked down again.
It'd be nice.
I forgot we have the DVR up in this bitch.
Yeah, there it is. Not right before
that, Jamie. Right before that. Oh,
right before there we go. This is
the money and here we go. Boom.
On the temple. But when that's good
chin back as a hundred percent good.
That's the side of the head.
Oh, that'd be the temple.
Let's say that's the back of the head.
Let me see that again.
You come from the home
and left. Took Bam. No,
no chance to make it slow.
Jamie and legal. Whoa. Hold on.
Hold on, but make it go slow. That's
a fucking temple dude. Watch it.
That would be bad. Hold on. Make
it slow. Isn't there a slow button?
There's a slow mo thing.
You press like a pause and then I dunno.
Double Pie.
I think pause and then a fast forward.
Yeah.
Oh, let me see that thing. Isn't there
like a small way you can do it slow Mo.
Pretty sure the rest. What does this
no network connection cancel. Hold on.
Oh he say it's back to what happened
here Jamie. Where am precedents to,
where's the receiver? It's in
there. Well how does it work?
Well it's not, it's not reacting.
Think got to hit cancel on that thing
for sure. Back in the head. But it's
legal. You know what I'm saying?
It's in transition. Okay, so it's legal.
Okay.
Um, take a look at it
better. That first view,
lets get a view of it in real time first.
Here it is right here. This is where
you can see it. Back to that. Boom. Bam.
See to me it looks like the side of the
head. Definitely. He's grabbing this.
He's grabbing pesticide the head and no,
that's not where he's grabbing
and he's grabbing like his temple.
How do I make this thing go slow?
Let me see if I can do this.
I think there's a way.
Yeah, here it is. Oh,
here we go. Okay. Okay.
I get the old crazy eyes on
him. Okay. Ready? Here we go.
It was Dustin Jacoby. Moving in. Check it.
Okay.
Mad pressure budget. Coby to
good defense. Good defense here.
Bear tried to swing that right hook around
left to Colby. Bank catches him here.
100% clean. That side of the head side of
the head, which is legit, right? Correct.
Okay.
Let's see.
We get a good view of it here and it
really relying on that right hand. Boom,
kind of Cassie if grazes that,
but that ones gets blocked.
That wouldn't gets blocked.
So now he's coming over again.
Bear it is or a Jacoby has misses
that left and now here we go.
It goes to the back of the head
to look at that.
Come on son.
Look where he's standing.
That's basically the back of look
where he's standing there standing,
staring at each other.
Homeboy moves though he moves his bear,
turns his head sideways and he
hits them right in the temple bra.
That's not in the template right here.
If we look at him,
it's not the bat not touching right there.
He's not touch as he
has a hook for an arm.
There's no fucking way that's hitting
the bag. No, look at it right there.
It's bouncing off the side of his head
and you see the fist appear behind his
head. One more time. One more time. Let's
watch it again. Watch it again. Boom.
That's one.
And there's the right hook misses,
and there's the left hook over the top
and here cubs. Here it comes. Look,
they're standing right at each other
and the punch comes, eh. Watch.
When the companies look at that,
that's not touching them and correct.
Incorrect. This is a straight punch,
right?
It lands on the side of his head and then
a glances off the side of his head and
you see the fist behind the head,
you'll fit is not no fucking chance.
There's not hitting the back of his head
that is hitting the side of his head
and you're seeing the punching glove.
It's like, here Joe look like, yeah, yeah,
that's legal dude. I'm not, it's illegal.
But I think, I think that's legal.
The same back of the head.
That's the side of the head will will.
It's the side of the head.
You got to punch me and I move like this
and you end up hitting side and back of
the head that's,
he's not hitting the back of the head.
So he didn't touch the back of his head
of his head. No. Touch side and back.
I don't know,
man.
Boom to me looks like
right behind the ear,
which is totally legit. The back of
the head to me is a rabbit ponch.
That's where the base of his neck
neat meets the face. The head.
That's the back of the year. That's
legal. That's not, that's does. No,
I think you're changing the game. No, no,
no. That's fine, bro. It's changing again.
Yeah, but it's not booming. It's
legal. That's kind of legal. Yeah,
it's totally legal. Yeah, I
agree. Or maybe I misunderstood.
Maybe I misunderstood.
I thought you were saying
communication here. That's all it is.
That's pretty slick though. It's a big
win for Jacoby, Matt. Real big win.
Oh Shit. Artem leavened top of
the heap. He's out though. Huh?
Well he's out for this fight.
You know, you look at that guy,
you look at his body and you're like,
it looks a lot like Ari Shaffir his body.
How's that guy? Such a bad ass,
you know man. If number four, Huh?
Well he's been fucked up
by Joe showing any sense.
How is he so highly ranked?
Well, Joe's too though. Awesome.
Well Joe Schilling hasn't really a lost
in glory other than the decision loss to
a Simon Marcus or did
that wasn't in glory.
The decision last to Artem leaven
a beat Artem 11 by decision too.
And then the decision
loss to Wayne Barrett.
Those are the fights
that he lost in glory.
So shilling getting paid bank to compete
in MMA for sure. Stick with kickbox.
I agree.
What the fuck are you doing?
I think he just doesn't want to back off
from a challenge and he wants to be the
best at everything he does. And that's
how he got to be such a bad ass.
Kickbox I agree, but be a bad ass.
Kickboxer it'll be an average MMA fighter.
Well it's just really hard to do
everything, man. It's really hard.
It's really fun to not do everything. It's
not possible. It's really not. It's a,
it's a crazy game man.
The game of trying to be the baddest
motherfucker and two disciplines.
That is a crazy,
crazy game cause they got,
the guys he's fighting aren't focusing on
their off time grappling and wrestling.
They're getting better at striking
100% that's what it's tough.
Like when I see that I
love, I love Joe, she'll,
and I see a friend of yours is
front of mind and I support him,
but when I see him do I have a man,
I'm like, what the fuck you doing?
Well you know what?
He knocked out Melvin Manhoef in MMA,
but he was fighting a guy,
Melvin Manhoef,
that even though we had a lot of
success in MMA, knocked out Mark Hunt,
he's a guy who's been knocked
out a gang at times. Hahnemann,
knocked out by Robbie Lawler and one of
the most horrific knockouts you've ever
seen your life. It was winning
that fight too. It was,
if you remember Robbie
Lawler uncorked a nuke from
and his lights went out and he
goes flat to his back so bad.
And Robbie comes down on
him when he's out and oh,
bismuth blood all over his mouth,
his blood coming out of his mouth,
and he busted his fucking
limp open. I think that, uh,
you know,
Joseph's just got that in him.
He just wants to be a bad
motherfucker at everything he does,
which is why I became so good at
kickboxing. But I think there's,
there's wisdom in your words.
He's one of the best kick boxers on the
planet earth without a doubt. Hands Down,
hands down, one of the best on planet
earth. But I think capsule, MMA fighter,
but losing the way he
lost that Japanese cat,
that half Japanese dude that he lost to,
who was that guy's name?
Where you got Superman Punch?
Yeah. That guy is a beast, man.
That guy's really good. He's no
joke. He's good though. The his,
his striking is nasty. That fucking
punch was nasty. No matter how you slice.
Super Nasty. I Isd, I'm just saying
it's still Bella tour. It is.
But that guy was the only fought
bell toward that one time. I mean,
that guy could have easily been in
the UFC and get good at Dow. Fuck. Ah.
Kobiashi dude. Never know. Yeah.
Yeah.
So I kind of get his ass up and uh,
we got 10 minutes left before
we go to three hours. So, um,
we're gonna take a
little break here folks,
and we're going to have a very short part
to the sh the part two will be so God
damn short, it's 10. What
is it? Nine 15 now actually,
we'll probably go to 10 o'clock. We'll
make part two like, um, 45 minutes.
We'll go to 10 o'clock. So, uh, we're
going to get the fuck outta here. Now,
the end of this podcast has come.
If you're a annoyed by this, listen,
this is just how these things
go. Whatever for sure. Don't,
don't download part too, because for sure
we just going to be talking about, uh,
our friend Joe Schilling. Well, I love
that dude. So, uh, that's why we're here.
That's why this is the first Spike
TV glory event we've ever done.
A fight companion,
400% for Joe Schilling.
This is what this is for moral
Renelle. Okay. Shied with skeletor.
We'll be right back,
right back.